beginning of every hearing or executive
session as chair of the House Education
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic thank
you and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a executive
session of bills referred to the
education committee executive sessions
on pending legislation may be
held please note that there's no fisical
Ed uh location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order I am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
27136 or email HCS ledge. state.
n.us in the event the public has unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us today Jer four our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states will
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to
so with that I would ask M cler I just I
just could take that he's gonna send you
an email Dan
yeah uh represent M just leave it yes
I'm sorry okay thank you we're we're
ready to go ahead what represent Shaw
would you please call the rle
representative
Celli here in the uh in the
L
representative here in the
L representative
here in the
L
representa in the
house
represent replacing
represent here in the committee
room here at home in Salsbury and I'm
home
alone
for home alone in
Chester represent Leon here in the
committee
room repres in the committee room
representative Miler uh here in kukuk in
my home office representative luno um
reporting from
Hopkinson representative in the
committee representative
home alone in
Manchester representative Tanner hi uh
home in George's Mills with my rescue
dog
Raven representative
Ellison I'm home alone here in
conquer representative mull here uh
dialing in from
Bedford representative
Le uh present from Jaffrey New Hampshire
and I am home alone repres
good here in Conway New Hampshire um
Home Alone currently but I expect my
bride to be in
anytime I'm here in L with the rest of
the that's here and I want to thank
everybody for tuning
today Rick it's hard for for us to hear
you you can hear me now right yes thank
you yeah you gotta PR press the blue
button in this room okay so with that uh
how many do we have present today Madam
clerk uh we have a full committee which
is 20 we have a full committee and uh
Deb represent Hopson is home uh with her
mother which is not doing
well um so
in going into our our docket for today
we have these three bills which we're
executing of which we're uh bringing
forward one of the bills which we
discussed yesterday which uh is uh the
six 08 we're still waiting for the um
amended language uh one of the things
we're changing on that was the effect of
date which was recommended through some
of the testimony we heard which is uh
appropo and we need to do that so as
soon as that comes we'll be able to jump
on that one also we are still waiting uh
for a Amendment for the
hb20 uh the amendment came through
yesterday but it had left off uh some of
the information that was supposed to be
included in that so that too we're going
to have to wait for that amendment to
come through we have received amendments
however for HB
594 uh FN that that's a bill which deals
with school building Aid we have
discussed this before um uh with uh in
conjunction with 214 which we did retain
that's a school building Aid Bill also
um this this bill right here is one
which uh is an early Bill
594 and so we will be discussing that
one at this particular
moment we have uh several amendments
here and I want to make sure that uh
there's nothing else in the in in the
hopper here as far as amending language
I have one that's uh from represent luno
that is
0243 um it's uh has an amendment which
deals with changing the the language uh
in the first portion of the bill which
deals with the $50
million there is a second uh Amendment
which is put forth by myself which does
the same thing for that section which
addresses the $50 million pretty much
accomplishes the same type of L uh end
um just the wording is a little bit
different uh and but it have the the one
I also have has a second par portion to
the bill which ID uh identifies the need
for a 10-year school facilities plan
plan uh done by the Department of
Education so are there any other
amendments out there on this particular
bill that that I don't have in front of
me
here representative lad have we have we
received those uh amendments I think if
you look on your computer you you have
received them we received them this
morning just before we started I
immediately sent them out to you I've
asked uh the folks who across the way to
email these to you upon uh they're being
completed evidently that's not being
done so that you you should have it uh
representative Miler on your computer
there as an attachment um I don't I
don't know sorry to interrupt
representative lad is it is it um
Amendment
400h yes yes I've just received that and
I'll send it out to the to the committee
do you need copies in the room no we
have copies in the room that was
provided to us but I also when I
received that I also got a copy by way
of electronics and that I sent it out to
all committee members you do that again
uh would you please Jen and we will
ensure that it's out there I believe
mine should be there in your inbox as
yeah it was sent at 9:27 am that
amendment that that's
correct okay so the question I asked are
there any other amendments out there on
this particular
bill
not not seeing any I will ask uh
representative cordelli for a motion
please uh thank you um Mr chairman uh I
would like to move on to pass with
Amendment uh to HB 594 number
H is there a
second order yeah the motion's wrong we
have a motion on so there's no point of
order no there is a point of order it
supersedes all
motions go ahead what is your point of
order represent I I believe the motion
would have should have been ought to
pass on the bill and then an amendment
um come on I think I I think that
absolutely what uh represent cordelli
was trying to say we're recommending he
would you please phrase your motion
represent cordelli yes I would like to
move ought to pass on House Bill
594 and offer Amendment 400h it's two
separate it's two separate motions you
can't motion is to adopt the
amendment we first consider the
amendment because there're two separate
votes so we have to vote on the
amendment first before there can be a
motion to that's correct but I believe
the wording um did I
offered uh came from the clerk but we
will be considering the amendment first
yes okay thank you need a second on that
Amendment represent leus is recognized
and she seconds the the amendment so now
we're uh open to discussion here uh and
I'm going to ask the maker of the motion
if he has any uh thing to say or or the
the person a second that represent leus
represent cordelli uh thank you um I I
think that uh one important part of this
amendment uh is the uh 10-year plan uh I
believe that uh this um addition to the
bill um was worked out uh with the uh
Department of
Education uh the uh facilities director
uh Miss Clark um and I think this would
help uh the department in planning for
um School renovation projects
uh okay thank you uh represent leus do
you have anything to
add just basically we do this with our
roads and it makes sense to do it with
our school buildings for for thank you
very much uh for those that are out on
on remote and and I haven't had an
opportunity to read the second portion
of it because the top portion is simply
addressing that we will Fund in terms of
school building Aid no less than $50
million right now you all know it it's
uh shall not exceed $50 million so we've
been funding the tail and as I've spoken
many times the tale for the first year
of this by by any we're looking at is
right around $32 million which leaves
$18 million for new and renovation
projects including emergencies uh
however we have not always at from a
policy perspective funded that total $50
million the previous year we funded
three
projects uh and and then the year prior
to that we had one emergency project
with
Hinsdale uh so it's uh and we've heard
so many times that we have all these
projects throughout the state with the
buildings being 60% of our buildings now
over or excuse me 50% of the buildings
right now that are over are over 60
years old so we we have some real
serious problems out there and we
discussed them in the hearing with it
with achievement that's related to
conditions within buildings HVAC
Acoustics lighting Etc the second part
of that bill deals with the 10-year plan
I'm going to read that for you so that
all folks can know what we're dealing
with it's a a section five within the
the bill here um
the Department of Education shall
develop and maintain a 10-year school
facilities plan of potential School
building Grant projects potential
projects shall include but not be
limited to criteria pursuant to RSA
19815 C Roman 2B the 10-year plan is
intended to create a method to identify
and enhance school facilities in a safe
healthy and efficient manner while
providing adequate learning environments
for New Hampshire students the 10-year
plan shall be updated every bium to
provide the department a summary of
projects and school facility Capital
expenditures that are anticipated for
the next 10 years the State Board of
Education shall adopt rule adopt rules
pursuant to RSA
541a relative to this paragraph the plan
shall identify new construction
renovation and emergency projects and
describe the overall condition of
projects contained in the
plan that that is the extent of this
amendment um is there
discussion represent luno thank you very
much Mr chair so um I'll I'll start out
saying that um that I'm not going to
vote to support the amendment but I I I
agree with both of the um the uh changes
that the amendment makes in fact um uh I
had offered an amendment last week um
that would have made the first imped the
first change um to make the um make the
financial part of of this bill $50
million um minimum including the tail so
exactly what um what representative lad
has put forward in Amendment 400h uh I
have talked also with um with director
Clark about the uh the 10-year plan and
how that would um um be an improvement
for um for school districts to at least
know where they are in the long-term
pipeline for for building projects it
takes a long time for school districts
to talk about building projects put them
together get the community on board vote
for um do a bond vote and uh and so I
think that would also be a good change
but the reason I'm going to vote against
the amendment is for what it loses um
first of all it um it retains the the
current um um pay the grant well it's
80% up front and 20% I think at the
completion of the project so you
basically get your Grant
uh when you uh when you do uh the
project and U we've already heard from
from director Clark that in the in the
first year of this bium um uh there will
or the first year of of fy22 there will
only be $15 million available so so
we've got a project backlog uh of with a
grant value currently of $104 million so
under the current um plan design uh only
only about um 15% of those projects or
15% of that project value is going to be
able to uh to be be awarded and um and
we know that that you know $14 million
of of um Grant value and that comes to
$270 Million worth of building projects
that's what we've got in the pipeline
now we haven't even opened the door yet
for the for the grant applications for
FY 23 and I think when the program comes
off moratorium there's probably going to
be substantially more um projects that
are that are applied for in the second
year of the bium there's going to be $18
million available for new projects so
again if um if we're if we're not
changing the plan design as is um as is
done in House Bill 594 the underlying
House Bill 594 then we're going to be
severely limited to the number of
projects the state's going to be able to
support what 594 does is change it from
100%
payment you know in the when the
Project's done to 20% and then and then
the balance gets paid in 20 equal
payments over 20 years so if we're
looking at a a current um projects in
the pipeline with $104 Million worth of
Grant value times 20% is about $20
million and we've got $15 million to um
to work with so we're going to be able
to get three4 of those projects approved
with the changes that are that are that
are made in the underlying Bill and are
removed with with the amendment that's
being proferred by representative blad
so that's the first thing that we lose
with the amendment um uh changing the
plan design to a 20% 20-year plan that
can go after the backlog and do it in a
responsible way the second thing we lose
is is a more is expanding the grant
range not the total grants that are
delivered but the grant range range from
currently 30 to 60% so if you're a well
healed Community lots of property values
you'll get a grant from the state of 30%
if you're if you're a very property poor
District under the current plan design
you can get a grant of of up to
60% um the underlying Bill 594 expands
that range from 30 to 60% to 20 to 80%
so that is much more commensurate with
the uh with the fiscal disparities that
we see across Ross the state in terms of
the ability for for local property
taxpayers to fund projects using using
local tax dollars um and in fact during
the uh during the hearing on that we had
on um representative Lads Bill House
Bill 214 and House Bill 594 I think
there was a substantial um uh commentary
provided by um by representative Hill
who's been involved in building projects
the only thing he liked about either of
these two bills was the uh was the
expansion of the uh of the grant range
to 20 to 80% so that's another thing
that we lose by by adopting the
amendment director Clark also said also
gave us information in the handouts that
showed even with the expanded range the
average Grant would still be the same um
so so we don't lose anything uh from
that we're just providing grants in a
more Equitable uh distribution across
the state and then the Third third thing
we lose by adopting this amendment is
the ability and this is in the
underlying bill for projects that were
started or completed during the
moratorium um period so projects that
were not able to be applied to to apply
for um for State Building Aid grants
would be uh would be considered and
there'd be a short time frame as
outlined in the underlying bill for for
these school districts to apply to the
department for building aid for projects
that were completed during the
moratorium um um just in Windham alone
just in Windham alone there was about a
$40 million project that would be
eligible for an $8 million retroactive
Grant under um under the underlying bill
of 594 so that's something that gets
lost when you um um when you adopt this
this amendment all
told the um projects that were completed
during the
moratorium um come up to
uh looks like about uh $500 million
worth of worth of projects the uh the
underlying Bill 594 does limit that
Grant to only 20% so you don't get the
full range on that but but it's it's
certainly something to to help out these
communities that just couldn't wait for
the state to uh to to get off its butt
and get the um and get the building aid
program put uh put back in business so
um so uh uh by adopting the amendment
yep two good things happen you increase
the total funding for the for the
program you improve the um the the
rulemaking authority of the department
that can help districts plan I agree
with both those two things but you lose
the improved plan design that can go
after more projects you improve the more
Equitable range of uh of funding
projects and you you lose the um the uh
uh the ability for projects that were
done during the moratorium to to
participate in this
program thank thank you very much uh
represent luno are there
further questions or
discussion uh I'd like to just make one
comment in in in regard to uh what Ron
luno has said yes there is a backlog of
projects no we're no longer in a
moratorium that has been done we did
fund the three projects last year that
were in the in in the
a hopper um the significant changes
within uh the 594 as initially sent
changes the application process and the
checks and balances within the uh School
building Aid approval process in fact it
totally eliminates the use of the school
building authority which is a balance to
the recommendations that come out from
the department and from the school
building authority the recommendations
go on to the school State Board of
Education for approval uh there's
confusion within the bill as it was
written as to is the state board going
to be approving these projects or is the
Department of Education going to be
approving these projects so that that's
the whole process has been jumped
without having any hearing on that
process at all and that was the point of
retaining
hb214 as to really dive into this whole
process in terms of what are the
strengths what are the weaknesses how
can we improve and how can we
gather that information and work with
doe to accomplish that desired end
secondly by reducing the amount of money
which is paid to a district upfront and
that's the
80% and the remaining portion of that
money from the state uh the other 20%
being paid upon completion of the
project I feel that that process will um
uh make it more difficult for the
districts which don't have the
wherewithal
the where with all to uh uh fund these
and it will also hamper I believe uh
approval these projects by the town
meeting process which is required to
have a two-thirds or at least a 60% vote
so that that is part of my concern the
other part is I'm I'm really worried
about what happens when we start uh
paying back the state's uh portion uh of
the debt of the principal uh over over
20 year period we're going to start
sliding back to where we were
approximately 10 years ago when the
state had a scheme not like this but we
had a scheme where we borrowing from our
Master Card to pay our Visa card and we
had $540 million of debt which we're
still trying to work off and that won't
be accomplished until year
2040 so uh this is a huge jump if we're
going to move ahead and and and and
adopt any of the other components of 594
as they were presented uh there are
significant issues with it uh I
understand the intent of the bill is to
try to support those poor districts um
by changing the whole scale from from a
30 to 60 to a 20 to an 80 uh but I I
don't think that is is necessarily the
correct answer and lastly with this
committee has discussed many bills in
the past which dealt with retroactive
payment uh projects which were started
during the of course the moratorium it's
been decided by the house on the floor
that no we're not going that direction
we're not going to back off those people
that went ahead in towns that went ahead
and uh in approv bonding that is on
their their s right now on there to pay
them to pay that off um the state's not
going to get back into that because
those projects were not approved through
this application process and and did not
pass through the the eyes in in the the
discussions of our director over there
Amy Clark so in conclusion I cannot
support U the full uh language in 594
however I do feel that the need for a
10year plan is absolutely needed and
it'd be a milestone if we can just get
the the state uh to approve up to $50
million uh in projects
lastly we have re received an Esser
Monies and in other monies uh funds
enough to take care of some of these
HVAC concerns within buildings the first
Esser Grant came down with 30 plus
million do the second one is well over
uh what $200 plus and then we I just
learned from the Department there's
another $300 million coming down from
the federal government these projects
are this money is available for
supplementing school and even supp
planning areas which are dealing with
issues specifically dealing with
facilities as is stated in the in the
grants so for those reasons I cannot uh
support the full 594 but I can uh
support as amended here in 0400 thank
you if um the people who are remote uh
could mute when they're not speaking
they're getting a little feedback I
understand so is there any further
discussion regarding regarding uh
594 the amendment the the
amendment with that Madam clerk would
you please call the role this is ought
to pass on Amendment
0400 representative
cordelli yes representative B yes
representative Allard yes representative
lus yes representative mofet yes
representative
Hobson yes
represent I'm sorry n representative
n yes n for
Hopson representative Andress yes
representative
Ford
yes represent Leon yes representative St
yes representative Miler no
question Representative luno no
representative Shaw no representative
Cornell
no representative
Tanner no represent Ellison no represent
Mullen no representative Le no represent
Woodcock no representative glad
yes
11 n okay we're ready for uh main
motion representative cordelli thank you
Mr chairman uh I would like to move
ought to pass on House Bill 594 FN with
Amendment
0400 is there a second representative B
thank you further
discussion yes represent luno thank you
very much um u m Mr chair chair um I'm
going to vote Yes on the um uh on the
amended uh bill it is certainly an
improvement over the um status
quo thank you uh further
discussion
any you have your hands up Mike okay uh
not seeing any further discussion on
this bill uh Madam clerk would you
please call the the
role yes this is ought to pass as
Amendment um
HB
594 representative cordelli yes
representative B yes representative
Allard yes representative lakus yes
representative Moffett yes
representative naer yes representative
Andress yes representative Ford yes
representative Lon yes representative St
yes representative miler
yes representative luno yes
representative Shaw yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Mullen yes representative
Le yes representative Woodcock yes
representative llad
yes uh with this bill being a a 20 but
it
uh does have
a well I would question whether there's
a financial note 214 said exactly what
this does on the part one and that's
what the law allows us to do right now
it's $50 million and the second part
doesn't so I don't know if there is a
financial note on this anymore um with
the the portions of the bill which were
in 594 not being attached with this uh
is there any objection to putting this
on consent no thank thank you very much
um no okay thank you very much
representative Miler um one comment I'd
like to make regarding this building Aid
I think we all recognize based upon this
vote that building Aid is a serious
issue in this state and we do have
several other bills which will be coming
up really dealing with this a topic or a
criteria within it HVAC acoustical sound
stuff those bills will be heard and
those they're all linked to to the issue
of of how we're taking care of our
facilities and how we're maintaining
them replacing them and building them uh
so that uh I think this discussion will
continue and as I've said before we will
initiate a subcommittee here as soon as
we get by this early Bill per period to
really start trying to take a dive into
this working with the department and and
working with folks in the field to try
to make some recommendations that can
move forward I thank you again for your
vote
today okay uh we have two other bills
and uh I've just got to find out whether
we've got the amending language back uh
has anybody seen the amending language
for hb20 or 608 yet um we have not had
this and I I need to get off this and
and give a call to OS and find out what
the status is so we will be taking
another break here on as we did the
other day I'm I'm sorry to have to do
that but uh it's things are just coming
out of there there were 40 bills stacked
up in OLS this morning for amending for
the various committees it's just not
moving quickly at all folks so Mr chair
yes represento yeah just a question on
the amendment that you're you're waiting
on for House Bill 20 is uh what's the
difference between that Amendment the
amendment that we received um yesterday
afternoon the I I believe excuse me that
that the amendment for
hb20 had NE negated to put on the second
uh uh author of the bill but but it also
left off all references to hold harmless
or the portion of the bill which would
allow a gradual reduction of funding to
support schools uh and that's that's an
important part of this whole equation we
had two primary focuses with that bill
one was to introduce the the concept of
eligibility being 375% of the FPL the
federal poverty level the second was
also to uh develop a hold harmless or a
waterfall effect towards the reduction
of funding to help support a ncon
stabilization because stabilization is a
term that brings a lot of bad memories
back to myself and I think others that
have been involved with school Finance
so uh we we do need to have that that uh
full Amendment available to us so you we
can have a healthy discussion and read
it and and then make the the decisions
we have to
make thank you you're welcome so is
there gonna
be go ahead yeah will there be a fiscal
note on
it uh is there a fiscal note attached to
this probably not there I will mention
that there is a not a fiscal note from
the LBA regarding
608 but you did get some information
sent to you from doe via uh my machine
this morning I received that from one of
the fellas that ref luno and I had
worked with several years ago over there
with uh uh Michael landrian and and uh
with Mark and he they have put together
a doe a a form or a sheet a a
spreadsheet which shows how this impacts
various t all towns municipalities in
the state so you might be opening your
machines up and looking at that we will
be referencing that I have not had a
chance myself to look at it I've been
told that it's been sent okay um Mr
chair yes yeah I also have a um it's not
a fiscal note but it's a um an email
from um from Michael Kain um with
respect to um um uh exposure of State
funds um would that be something that
members of the committee would be
interested in reviewing if you if you
have a copy of that would you please
send it out to all committee members
okay we'll do thank you so we're going
to um take a a recess here um and um see
what time is it right now 5 after 5
after 10 uh I would say that it it would
be probably another 20 25 minutes before
so let's pick this thing up at 10:30
okay good thank you represent LE do you
have a question you're good CL are
trying to turn that on off button huh
good catch you later 10
10:30
yeah
what
okay
e
see
look
okay
for
[Music]
did
so
girl
right
right that's one that was one of
questions then the other issue on the
severability question which is at the
end of there it's a whole another it's a
whole another set of questions around
what what does that
mean or the no liability for the
scholarship they need to provide some
explanation for
that
no scholarship Organization for the
state that's on U page
n no
liability y
yeah so so all right since you just
since you just got on here we're gonna
use this as another caucus we're gonna
listen to what Rick has to say on uh
hb20 okay and then I'm gonna ask for him
to set up another hearing on this thing
because of all the changes that are here
he'll deny that and then we'll move into
a caucus okay good thank you
our caucus yes and I'm G I'm gonna
request about a a 30 minute caucus for
this okay because of the because of the
radical nature of the changes here right
um so so just for okay Noel for for I
know we got a we got a leap in a minute
but just for planning purposes um how do
we how long do we think the are G to go
today we just have one more after this
so okay I've I I have to um I have to be
in ways and means but I'll have I'll
have another laptop going um not sure
which one he's gonna move to whe he's
gonna move to
608 right
now yeah we're losing you all right we
got to jump right okay all right
right
for
just
what
for
but that I mean look
was like town clerk was feeding in those
Ballance can you hear me out
there we have the
amendment hearing
that can the rest of the committee hear
me out there can you hear
us yes we can okay thank you um we uh
have been in touch with uh Anthony to
cross away in in the legislative
Services plus the uh person writing this
this legislation for both these
evidently something was done and sent
but it's
been not we could we couldn't locate it
but they're redoing it right now now as
we speak so as soon as th those two
amendments come for 608 and
hb20 um we'll forward them to you and I
would assume that it's my assumption
that you would like to have probably a
caucus or some something to get together
and discuss um both of these uh
amendments would you prefer something
like that repent
Miler yeah I think what we'd like to do
uh Mr chairman is to have an
explanation have explanation of the
amendment have you go through that
explain the changes U and your
recommendations on that and then at that
point in time uh the uh Dem caucus will
take place so that we can uh review your
comments and uh our response to those
comments if that's appropriate both the
MERS were just s out okay uh yeah both
of the amendments were just set out I I
don't have them in front of me right now
but uh we could uh open up uh
hb20 and and look at uh that Amendment
explain that and then provide you an
opportunity to have a caucus it is um so
um we have folks here that are familiar
with that Amendment but uh unfortunately
we don't have it line by line on the new
one so
um what we we need to do is uh can you
pull that up in your computer re
cordelli
yeah just to P yeah that's what we're
GNA
do what we like to do is you know he
will have an on his
screen and he can go through the
amendment the amendment for HB well I I
I I'm not going to guess I've not seen
it yet so I'm not going to project what
was put in it or not in terms of who's
sponsoring it it's supposed to be myself
and representative Allard on the
amendment which which amendment are we
referring to Rick hb20 0398
0398 come on come on come on come
on up it landed in our legislative
email 0398 is in your legislative email
yes I see that thank you representa
Mullen I can't 0398 the Network's
slow yes
yes seems I have a problem with page
three do do you have that in front of
you right now represent it does every
can
I I know it's quite a leap for some to
get that you know that on one computer
and then be also doing this as well but
you could put Pull It in front and then
you could be still talking uh with your
Zoom
um9
039 I'll save
it we can start walking through that if
it's uh if you're ready for that out
there in the remote country then we got
six
wait question Mr chair yes represent
Woodcock thank you I did my due
diligence last night on 0365 H um so is
there going to be and I'll listen to you
intently this morning on the change the
new one is there any major differences
besides that one section you said prior
to the break about whole h
no there there should not be any changes
that is was something that was just left
off by the writers okay so so what we'll
do now is we'll do a brief thank you
you're welcome represent Woodcock we'll
do a brief overview of that Amendment he
too polite and then uh if there's any
questions regarding that and then we
will you know allow caucus to
occur so um represent cordelli could you
take us through that Amendment please
thank you uh yes um this is in response
to what we heard um at the hearings um
our two days of
hearings so I I'll start on uh page one
um with the uh eligible student uh Roman
6 and um this uh section was a
simplified um and in a uh it's
simplified to to say that a resident of
the state who's eligible to enroll in a
public school qualifies but we added
that the household income must be less
than or equal to
375% of the federal poverty uh
guidelines and that currently for a
family of four is approximately
$99,000 and that would mean that
approximately half the families in the
state would
qualify um going down to Romans
7 um we added in that this satisfies
compulsory attendance
requirements uh this has to do with uh
categories of students that qual that
meet uh compulsory attendance currently
they are three uh in number they are
public school students private school
students and homeschool students and so
in this and two other places we clarify
that uh there is a now a fourth category
that being EFA
students um proceeding on to the next
page page
two um coming down to
um uh
Roman 2 uh B we clarified
that EFA funds tuition uh expenses can
be used to go to a public school outside
of their resident District uh this is a
clarification um and we also added that
the EFA funds are to be used for that uh
tuition at a out of District public
public school and that the department
should make no adequacy payment to that
school for the student so to is avoid
any duplication of funding there and
that same um elimination of possibility
of duplication is added in e in relation
to curricular activities and
programs coming down to
Jay
um we just changed
that um from uh I believe it was just a
national standardized uh test to a
nationally standardized Norm reference
achievement
test as an allowable
expense uh proceeding on to page
three um in rooman 7 uh there was just
um a wording change in some places in
the uh Bill uh it had said intentional
and substantial Mis use of funds in some
places had just substantial so we went
back and added the same language in all
those locations to read intentional and
substantial misuse of
funds coming over to page
four um this is where we
added um in response to hearing comments
uh similar uh academic
accountability uh Provisions that we've
had in Prior legislation and you'll see
that in number three that is um in what
I'm looking at is
um line nine or
10 and um the parent is to provide an
annual record of of
attainment um by one of three means one
is to take that nationally standardized
Norm reference achievement test that we
had defined as an allowable expense uh
they can take uh the Statewide student
assessment at a public school or
maintain a portfolio or educational
record um including uh
materials um and uh workbooks uh created
by the student during the year and that
would be uh reviewed by a uh teacher um
which is similar to Provisions in uh the
uh homeschool
laws coming down to Roman
8 which I believe is on line
24 or
um maybe I might have the wrong line
number but it's um
um that uh if the student uh the the
student may withdraw from the program
and enroll in another qualified program
uh this goes back to the separation of
categories uh to clarify that EFA
students are not homeschool students so
a student an EFA student can withdraw
from the EFA program U and go back into
public school or to a private school or
um into
homeschooling um going on to page five I
believe scroll down um in uh Romans
6A uh there was just a typo in the uh
reference number uh to an RSA um prior
in the uh bill um that's on line uh
27 proceeding to page
six um again just the uh change to make
it intentional and substantial misuse of
funds um on to page
7 uh the scholarship organization uh May
adopt
guidelines or procedures we just changed
this from Rules or procedures uh to uh
clarify that uh as stated in the um
section just above that that uh the
State Board of Education adopts
rules proceeding on to uh page eight and
the uh advisory commission that's
established um we just
clarified uh there was a typo in the
number of members that there are 13
members um in total and that the um uh
legislative uh members as well as the
Director of the scholarship organization
and the commissioner are non voting
members um and
then
I see where the um line number is um
should be on page nine I believe that we
added um what is called the um it's a
194 E10 line
um uh phase out
grants or hold harmless grants
um basically with this provision uh the
first year that a student lead Lees a
public school the public school is going
to get 100% funding for that student
since um payments are a year
behind with this addition in the second
year after that student leaves the
district would get
50% of that student's uh Grant and then
25% in the third year so there is a a
draw down or phase out um of the funds
for the uh district for each student so
they don't hit get hit in the second
year with a complete loss of funds for
that student uh to try and help with
their uh budgeting and
planning um so that is uh the new
provision in this amendment um
0399 um and
I'll mention also on the last page uh
two two things
here
um in line
18 uh again this is related to
compulsory attendance and that uh EFA
students are a new category and that's
what you'll see in um section three the
new subparagraph to the compulsory
attendance
law
and the uh number four line
22 uh
the income uh limit of
375% is
repealed in uh July of
2026 uh this is a a trial period if you
will um to uh see how the program is
going so that uh income limit would be
repealed and we also have the
legislative oversight committee that is
in effect that will monitor how the
program is going and they can make
recommendations such as U
extending uh the income limit or um uh
what they think is
necessary and uh just to be uh be
um full uh clarification also I'll
mention with that phase out program I
want to go back to that uh because I
think left out one fact related to that
um that also uh phases out the the
phaseout grant provision um would end
for new EFA students in July of
26 uh just as this um the income uh
limit does so that uh a new if EFA
student um leaving the district after
July 20
26 there would be no phase out grant for
that student however if uh a student
left in
2025 and was let's say in the second or
third year of their um departure um
those grants would continue for any uh
student had who had left prior to that
uh 2026
date so those are the um I think the the
main things included in this uh
revision and um I think it addresses a
number of the
concerns um and comments made at the
public
hearings um and um we hope it will uh um
meet some of those criticisms and
um we think it uh really improves the
bill and uh will be um more acceptable
to school districts um and still be
uh accomplishing what we wanted to do in
terms of helping students throughout the
state thank you Mr chairman you're
you're welcome uh so with that um the if
uh any individuals on the committee have
questions regarding the amended language
uh as presented in
398 a
um now is an opportunity and then what
we'll do is uh once we go through the
question period then we'll enter into
the caucus um represent Miler yeah Mr
chair uh I I
respectfully asked the chair to create a
hearing on this bill this is some these
are major changes in a controversial
bill that we've received hundreds of
emails on and thousands of people have
monitored this
process and it seems to me that with
these major changes that have just come
about in the last 10 15
minutes that there is reason that there
should be another
hearing so that who have voes these
changes and I I would respectfully
request the chair to set aside this at
this point in time and create a hearing
so that people can uh we have a chance
to to really look at this I there's some
major issues here that in you know the
time remaining even in today to try to
uh far it out the various issues I mean
this this is this is a major
shift in how we provide educational
opportunities for students in the state
and I would submit that uh we need to
have more time on this I mean we were
prepared to deal with what was already
presented in the hearing
before but these are major issues here
that I I would submit that we need to
have a hearing and and put this aside
until we have that
hearing are there are there any other uh
uh comments at this point in time uh I
will respond to this it's the the whole
principle and concept behind this
legislation and the intent of this
legislation has been known
from from its uh start uh the the
concept is to provide the educational
opportunity for those that just need
another alternative situation or pathway
uh to achieve their Public School
experience um so I don't see what where
you're saying this is a major shift
there there's some changes in here in
terms of Eligibility those changes are
not anything really different than it
was has been been discussed um uh
through conversations or through even
earlier
legislation um the concept of a phase
out is one where uh it it supports some
of the concerns that uh individuals had
regarding assistance to districts during
this initial startup um whether in
phasing it out yes but it does as
representative cordelli said provide the
opportunity for a discussion through the
over site committee so I I I'm not uh
accepting the fact that this is a a
major change it's um just refining this
bill as we normally do with most bills
with amending language it's a followup
Mr chair yes there are ma there's a
major fiscal impacts here you're talking
about additional uh funds that are going
to be made available to not only
students but you're also talking about
additional fiscal impact on the on the
trust fund uh to
in the uh to school district for those
students who are leaving and yet we have
not seen any phisical not fiscal note on
what the impact of this bill is to the
State education trust fund that alone
should say to me that that we need to
have at least that before we can pursue
uh concluding this the discussion on
this bill uh representative Miler I
don't think that you're going to get an
answer to your question there until this
bill reaches Finance where the people
that are properly prepared to delve into
fiscal matters we are a policy committee
and so we're addressing here the policy
associated with uh
hb20 however we don't we don't I I I
don't disagree from the policy question
but in the past Rick we we have looked
at not only the policy but also the
fiscal impact when we have the numbers
and we don't have any numbers here and
and that's very troubling to those of us
that are concerned about the the uh
policy question here but uh to submit
this to the finance without an
understanding of what some of the fiscal
impact might be I think it's just
irresponsible thank you um I'm GNA move
on a couple other question I see the
represent L has his hand up yeah thank
you Mr chairman I just want to Echo what
representative Miler is stating here I
mean um I understand that we're a policy
committee and not necessarily fiscal but
this new Amendment actually addresses
certain fiscal matters and adopts them
as policy okay so you are already
considering issues of cost by putting in
this phase out you have acknowledged
that cost is part of the policy in this
committee and therefore there should be
fiscal knowledge uh of the overall cost
as part of our consideration of the
effects of this policy by your own
admission in this amendment thank you
thank you further further
discussion representative
lus yes um normally when we have a
public hearing on something we then look
at all of the input that was given
during the public hearing we make
amendments based on that input we do not
have another public hearing at after
that we have discussion amongst the
committee what we did here was we took
the majority input that we got from all
of the people during two public hearings
and included those in the bill we
responded with the things that people
were asking for and so at this point
what we would normally do this is normal
procedure is at this point we would not
have a public another public hearing
I've never actually heard of that we've
responded to the two public hearing
hearings and now amongst the committee
we would discuss how we responded and
was this sufficient thank
you so uh at this point in time uh
represent mil are you requesting a
caucus
yes how long do you uh see that having
to be I would see between 30 and 40
minutes
please okay so what we'll do is that uh
seeing that you're going to be uh
caucusing for that period time then
we'll just tie in lunch on the back side
of that and come back so if I add uh the
look at the clock right now it's roughly
around 11 o'clock um so that if you take
uh to to 11:45 and then we come back and
we start this thing back up at 12:30
fine represent LE I see you have your
hand up and so is luno represent luno um
thank you very much Mr chair um just to
just to clarify when we come back um
that's when we're going to be able to to
ask questions about the um uh the
amendment and um make and and have uh uh
essentially have
deliberations we will when we come back
we will have a motion to uh address this
amendment and and then we'll get into
discussion on on the amendment which is
basically the bill um so that that will
be our
process well I think if I may though I
think there may be questions that we
might
have uh for points of clarification
before we get actually get into the
discussion or the debate on this bill
because I think there as we begin to
review this amendment there are are
going to be some questions come up and I
think the question period is a little
different than the actual debate that
would be my
suggestion thank you I'll take that into
consideration thank you you're welcome
so at this point in time we are going to
recess and we'll come back at
12:30 uh and and during that period of
time we will have both opportunity for
caucus and lunch thank you very much
thank
you representative lad I'll be muting
your audio and video for the room at
this time thank you very
much
am
despite recogniz
power
never
radi
cultural could now be gone from this
Earth
talking any R
Radio
he way so many
others I of comment
a r has been
I with their
focus with their thoughts resp
emails
he
Young
fascinated
withs and he tried to that
the himself he
also
of I don't want any of that I want it to
go
away
feary 202
Iowa office news out
of months later after
his fight he has this awful
awful I remember that I
of
own those listeners Russ
viewers and I would just said when they
say representative Ford can you mute
please
Okay one
minute oh darn
it where is
it oh come
on should be a little microphone down in
your lower left
corner
does any know the reason why we're
waiting
or they had a long enough lunch
hour we were waiting for you
Steve you'd be the first we we we
I don't know about that meeting with
Trump on his web
page a primary source comp's actually
involved right yeah so I prefer that
yeah do you know how to get a letter
printed out in this day and
age for here where here even Ash
Wednesday's going help me
today to
because oh because then people would
have to be around I'll pray for you
Steve like send it to us when we had a
secretary
or and then she could but now we don't
have
any that makes
sense like blur and what not I just used
the email if I didn't have it send it
and then she'd oh yes I need to find
out
I'll run as fast as I
can hi for the session with the you guys
have is is it the people who made the
motion and wrote the committee report
who soon to speak on them oh in the
we'll talk about that yeah we haven't
done that yet okay but we can talk to
you about okay I can work on preparing
for those right that's what I mentioned
to him this morning I'll do the nurses
bill but let me know so I can write ni
and then I can wear my new red suit
dress I've been saving it for something
powerful M want to pass it what's that
mine pass it yeah but mine is it's
um maybe we can get R to wear his red
dress also yeah I think you should well
it'll be for for heart disease because
there'll be so many heart attacks when
you wear a red dress up to the
podium no and keep I would say keep your
speech
to two pages of 16 point Ty then you go
it yeah no more than three minutes two
pages 16 point that works good and the
biggest thing is you need to make sure
you don't get bored listening to your
own speech because then other people
will I'm like I'm already bored with my
speech now I need to change
it good afternoon can folks hear me out
there okay good thank you very much
uh so we're ready to go ahead uh we have
for executive session this afternoon HB
20 and five uh and 608 excuse me um I'm
not going to be taking any motions at
this particular time um I'm I feel that
there's really still a need for a little
bit of discussion regarding hb20 and
certainly with HB
608 um so um I'd like to uh continue
with hb2 we were when we when we left
off
um I I listened to uh some of the
discussion beforehand that was coming
from those that are all remote and there
are some concerns there uh that we heard
um and so I would like just to open this
up to discussion to further discuss um
uh hb20 uh with all people here on the
committee um is is there anybody that
has a question or a comment regarding
hb20 yes representa Tanner uh thank you
chairman um I in going back through the
the uh
hb20 and looking specifically at all the
things that the scholarship committee is
uh designated to do I noticed that in
some places it's called a scholarship
committee and in other places it's
called the scholarship committee um and
right now we have actually two
scholarship committees giving out the
educational tax
scholarships uh the children's
scholarship fund and the giving and
goinging Alliance and as I go through
hb20 uh again and the places where the
scholarship organization is supposed to
make all these rules and oversight and
forms for parents and um oversight on
the spending um I'm wondering how that's
going to be split up right now between
two scholarship committees and certainly
um if others came in and wished to uh be
recognized as a scholarship committee
for this purpose I'm sure that they
could get uh approval by the Secretary
of State and the um budget
office oh repr
cardelli uh thank than you Mr chairman
um first of all a scholarship
organization has to uh go through the
Department of Revenue Administration and
get approved by then and uh I believe uh
in Prior discussions with the Department
uh that there would be an
RFP so if there were multiple um just as
a followup if there were multiple
scholarship I
can't hear you represent Tanner are you
did yes um as a followup um just if
there's multiple organizations handling
this uh information this oversight for
example the oversight committee where
the scholarship committee um
appoints uh you know seven members to it
um I don't see any way in this bill that
that organiz that type of organization
and and I have to reiterate that the
scholarship organization has taken
over uh a lot of what a Department of
Education would do or um the education
laws it it takes that whole uh part of
the oversite out how how is that going
to work intertwine with multiple
scholarship
organizations uh as I tried to indicate
there would be an RFP issued and there
would be one scholarship organization
managing the accounts so as a followup
to that so we're setting up a monopoly
for one scholarship organization that's
going to receive 10% of the monies that
go into that scholarship Organization
for administration and and whatever is
that is that what I'm led to believe at
this
point I do not believe that you could uh
legitimately call it a monopoly you
would be uh awarding a contract uh with
an organization to manage the
accounts Mr
chair representa Ellison's had his hand
up representative Ellison thank you Mr
chairman I I'd like some clarification
if I can get it from sponsors of of the
of the bill relating to uh page seven
lines 15 to 18 which talk about
uh you should not exclude discriminate
against otherwise disadvantage any
educational provider with respect to
programs my question is that if you have
an educational organization a school for
instance which could be a Jewish school
a Muslim School a Christian School
whatever it was and in in its mission
statement it said that homosexuality is
a sin and gay people will not be allowed
to enroll in
school would uh an EFA still be accepted
or EFA be given to that school if that
was the
situation there are federal
anti-discrimination laws that apply to
all our
organizations uh but at the same time a
religious institution is not going to be
required to change the basic tenants um
of their faith or
practice follow up Mr Mr
chairman uh well then if if in fact the
basic tenant of the school was
that only Muslim Students would be
accepted that you had to be a a believer
in that faith and no one else could be
would that come under that particular
Clause of a religious exception to the
rule I'm not sure that's a that's a
hypothetical question I I don't know
um uh but uh I do know that it would be
unconstitutional uh in my opinion I'm
not a a lawyer or desire to be a lawyer
um but uh it would not be uh valid to
have an organization be required to
change uh you know we've seen Court
decisions recently uh in the past couple
of years uh about uh with healthc care
and requirements for organizations to do
various things um in opposition to the
tenants of their faith so I I think you
could look to those Court
decisions further
question Mr chair yeah just a procedure
here uh could I suggest that we start on
page
one and go through the various sections
so that there's some sense of order uh
to raising questions of Representative
cordelli so it's it's not just all over
the map but we can go right through and
go through and raise a serious qu raise
whatever question someone might have on
a particular if there's no question then
we just move right on I'm just
suggesting that as a
procedural move
here I have no objections to that
process all right so so uh will will all
of us does everybody have have it either
up on their computer or have a copy of a
a hard copy
available so we'll look at um page one
good and if there's um someone with a
question uh referencing page one page
one includes
definitions and also uh one of those
definitions is that of an eligible
student yeah well before we get there I
have a question question on uh line
uh it talks about an education service
provider means a person or organization
that receives payment but it does not
have any sense of definition of what is
an educational provider uh can somebody
clarify for me what that means it it it
it appears that there's no qualific
appliation whatsoever as far as
credentialing experience Etc so could
somebody clarify that for me
please I thought it was pretty
self-explanatory I can't hear you GL
sorry you're mut yeah I'm not used to
pressing the microphone button um I'm
lucky if I can press it on my computer
um the uh I thought it was pretty
self-explanatory it can be either a
person in or organization that provides
services it could be a a private school
um it could be a teacher who's working
with students
um or a store that sells a
curriculum so with that though I mean I
I think we may have raised this before
so if uh if I want my member of my
family for example uh to be a tutor of
my child
that Tut
then could you're
you're a education service provider is
that
correct let let me try can you hear me
better now yes yes okay so my question
was is that if if I have a member of my
family for
example who I would select to be a two
of one of my children that individual
family member could be an education
service provider is that
correct I think that uh anyone looking
to educate their children if they are
looking for a tutor is going to uh
select someone who is qualified in the
subject matter that they are looking to
teach certainly for a tutoring facility
um we have a number of organizations
around the state that provide tutor
green services that I think would be
qualified to uh perform that function
that's not if I may uh Mr chair that
doesn't answer my question I understand
that there are there are those kinds of
providers out there but there is no
qualification for what is a education
service provider that's really my point
and my concern that there's no
definition of what that individual might
be organizations IND uals Etc that's my
concern on this this particular
definition thank you represent
leus yes I was asking some of these
questions um over the last few months
and my understanding is that
um we'll be using class wallet and in
order for anybody to get paid through
class wallet they have to have um gotten
clearance from the scholarship
Organization for money to be able to go
to them so for somebody who wants to be
a service provider has to sign up
through the scholarship
organization and um so there's oversight
there as to who would be doing that or
they would not get
money further questions representative
uh
leay thank you Mr chairman um before I
ask my questions I would respond to the
previous comment there that um oversight
there is no oversight there um for
example if my spouse has a different
last name than I do the scholarship
organization would have no idea that we
are uh married um and since there seems
to be no provision for any sort of
qualifications to make a judgment um
obviously it would go through um we need
to be talking about the specifics and
the things that are actually in the bill
not what we think people might do um I
have a specific question though um and
This concerns um the definition of an
eligible student actually uh just two
questions one um so as far as the way
the definition goes if I were 40 years
old and I did not graduate high school
am I
eligible no 20 no no an eligible student
for uh Public School in New
Hampshire am I eligible to go back to
public school in any way if I didn't
finish high school if I did not graduate
no no
okay second question um the
375% uh or actually no um actually I'll
wait I'll wait I'll
wait sorry if I may it's the
representative Leon the the right now a
public school student is no longer a
public school student after their 21
years of age that's in the statutes okay
thank you I said no right uh and if I
could go back um there are provisions in
numerous places for the scholarship
organization where there is a
substantial misuse of funds uh to report
that to the department and to the
Attorney General's office it needs to be
substantial and intentional
correct okay are are there further areas
that let's walk through and again look
at specific areas within so we can all
respond uh representative
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman um I'd
like to follow up on representative
mil's comment and the answer from
representative cordelli when you're
talking about the service provider and I
know you didn't want to flip forward but
on line
19 of page eight going back to that
comment it says providers ECP providers
the service scholarship organization May
provide approve education service
providers of our own
initiative doesn't say anything about
going through the
process page 19 I mean page eight line9
the scholarship organization May approve
Education Service Providers on its own
initiative at the request of parents but
no it to a Sol organization so it's it's
not as clearcut as it may seem by
representative quell's presentation that
they're going through
this uh
program thank you
represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair um I
also have a um a question with regards
to on on page one with regards to the
the the definition of an eligible
student and um I want to talk about it
with the training wheels taken off
basically the the repeal at the uh at
the end of this bill that um that
repeals um Roman 6 which is the
definition of an eligible student so I'd
like the questions I have answered in in
that context so my first question is
would um would students who live in New
Hampshire and currently attend public
private or Charter or H schools be um uh
be
eligible
yes first of all I'm not sure what
you're talking about in terms of
training wheels all right well basically
Paras secondly can I finish my answer
thank you uh secondly wa when when when
I talk about that I'm talking about the
repeal language I thought I was pretty
clear on that well I'm not familiar with
the training wheels reference well
that's what it's what you called it you
said we wanted to give it a try for a
few years and then and then open it wide
up that's pretty much what TR training
wheels do well let Let's uh let's not go
there okay folks let's keep you know
what I'm talking about you know what the
question is
go go ahead uh representative cordelli
do you have want to respond to
that could you restate your question uh
sure sure I in in the context of this
bill with Roman 6 on page one
repealed based on the the repeal
language in the
bill would a student who lives in New
Hampshire and attends either a public
private Charter or is homeschooled be
eligible for this
program the uh yes the right now the uh
student who is homeschooled in a private
school or a public school is eligible
okay and a I've got a couple of
follow-ups on that because I W to take
it through and really understand what an
eligible student who is eligible for
this program once the um once Roman six
is is repealed so um would would a
student who is uh in New Hampshire um or
let me say it another way would a person
uh who lives in New Hampshire and is
over the age of
18 um be eligible for this
program yes if they haven't graduated
from high school uh yeah if they haven't
graduated from high school right now we
have uh 167 year olds um who are in uh
program called diploma programs paying
for tuition at schools so they can uh
get their uh uh degrees from high school
okay and but we also have um 20 and 21
year olds also that that don't have a
high school degree that's correct and
they would be eligible for this program
all right I want to push it I want to
push it a little further because it's
really important to understand who's
eligible
um for this so I I appreciate the
chair's Indulgence um on this and um and
and so would would a student who dropped
out of high school let's say when they
were
18 never
graduated and then and now they're
23 would they be eligible for this
program no I do not believe so all right
could you point to the the particular
piece in the um bill which would um
which would support that
answer age okay well we're not gonna in
the bill for
age I got
it I mean could this be one of the
things that's judged by no government
intervention or stuff like
that uh I think um we see where you're
going with this
um excuse me I think we see where you're
going and um you know would have been a
lot simpler um to uh ask a direct
question but um perhaps the a was uh
left out of that repeal provision um in
the
redrafting okay so I want to keep going
I really want to understand this so so
so age no longer is a is a consideration
so I think representative Le's question
the answer I think is is probably yes so
now I want to now I want to move forward
to a student whose F who lives in
Connecticut who attends a a a private
school in New Hampshire would they be
eligible for this
program family lives in
Connecticut
yeah it's a question not that is not the
intention um and if we need to look at
that repeal language we
will well what's the so is there
anything in the in the in the bill that
would prevent
that um I'll stand by my previous
comment okay um all right so I guess my
my final comment on this would be for
for somebody who when was when they when
you were in when they were introducing
the amendment talked about the fine
attention to detail on statutory
references yet left the barn door wide
open to anybody to take advantage of
this program at any age from any state
in any educational setting or not um is
just is just frankly
unbelievable are there further
questions I'm not
gonna representative uh
uh
late well I was just going to ask are we
still on we're on page one yet is that
it
yeah well we're we're just moving
through in accordance with uh yeah the
request of uh represent Miler so are we
done with page one I I have a very
simple question which I noncontroversial
um at the bottom of page one it
references in a definition remote or
hybrid um but the doesn't seem to be any
further reference to that that I could
see in the amendment so I was just
wondering why that was in
there
Jesus homeschool go to high school for
one that goes back to uh the original uh
bill and the definition of an eligible
student where we did talk about remote
and
hybrid
so okay all right that's
questions yes representa
MF yeah thank you Mr chair uh still on
the subject of eligible students I have
a message from another state
representative to which is a good good
question with regard to a a student who
is currently in a hybrid status there
are those that are out there who
homeschool but they they do one or two
classes or whatever so the the question
is how is is such a person who's a
hybrid student taking one or two classes
and doing mostly homeschooling could
could they be eligible for this program
and and and along with that how would
that impact uh you know the the money
award and the budget you know the uh you
know the money that the school would
have
gotten if you're tracking that that
situation with a hybrid student right a
hybrid student student or student in
remote learning um would uh leave their
um resident Public School District and
sign an agreement for an EFA and become
an EFA student oh right and the the
question that I think she has and I have
as well is how would that impact uh I'm
not clear we're not clear on the the the
money that that the school gets you know
for a full-time student you know from
the uh from the
state if this student um is a part-time
student it's just not clear as to if
they go from part-time to full-time EFA
how how does that impact there is no
part-time EFA or either in one of
several categories public school student
private school student homeschool or EFA
student right so what I'm trying to say
it's not I understand the EFA situations
not PRI time but if a student is a
hybrid student who is has a mixed
situation like I said where they are
mostly homeschooled but taking some
classes it's just not clear on how this
would impact the you know the the a you
know the awards that that the the
monetary awards that go to the uh to the
schools now if if they're losing hybrid
student go ahead repent like this okay
this was a question I had um a few
months ago and did track down um
currently if a student is homeschooled
and takes some classes at the high
school the state pays a pro-rated amount
to that high school if they are in
EFA they have all of that state money
comes to them in the EFA so if they take
some classes at the high school they're
required to pay out of their EFA to the
high school and that's why it has
specifically in here that the state will
not pay the high school for those
students because the state has already
paid the student for those classes so
they don't double
dip thank you that clears that up Son
thank
you on on that point uh Mr chairman I
think the issue of payment for part-time
students is subject to each school
district and the little research that
I've done is it seems that there really
is um a mixed uh practice of how PE how
students who either homeschooled or in
this instance would be able to
participate in other programs in the
school some have some fees frankly most
don't have
fees we have in statute where if you you
are a homeschooling student you have the
opportunity to attend a public school uh
and if you attend that one as I've
mentioned before that one science course
in the high school the high school may
be reimbursed depending upon the uh
status of funds available here in the
state a 0.15 or about 15% of the adma
cost for that kid the adequacy cost um
and so that that's how we have set that
up we have put that in the statute I
think you've been a part of it or when
we did this um now in terms of a middle
school or Elementary School student that
is not applicable to that particular
statute is not applicable to them seeing
that they're not set up by courses
they're set up by entire school program
or grade level
program uh rep representative uh
I'm going right across the screen here
back and forth with the four of you here
um represent LE thank you Mr chairman
thank you for indulging uh just to so I
I just want to I'm trying to get my head
around this so we say that does it say
somewhere in this amendment that you you
cannot be enrolled in your
resident Public School
District yes
okay but now it seems that if you're
less than four 50% you can attend your
resident Public School District and be
on the EFA is that correct I just want
to make sure I understand
that no
the you're either a public school
student or an EFA student but the but an
EFA student can sign for work in their
resident public school as long as
they're doing it for less than 50%
because the definition
they they can take courses at their
public school as a homeschool student
currently can as just described by the
chairman okay all right thank you I just
wanted to make sure I understood thank
you represent
leas rather than the big goor round that
we had earlier yes there was a bit of a
mistake in the um repeal part I think
the part that was meant to repeal was um
not just not just a but I think the
second half of a and it just didn't get
referenced right um trying to do this we
send in one thing we get something else
back and so this is frustrating for us
too and it didn't it we knew what was
supposed to be referenced but that is
not what got referenced the idea was the
part that was less than or equal to
375% is the part that
would be repealed but could be looked at
before that to say or even repeal it and
say well we want a different number
there or we don't need it anymore or we
or continue it at that point it would be
revealed and I mean Ral reviewed and
then um figure out what to do the part
of eligible to enroll in a public
elementary or secondary school was not
supposed to be repealed it just when
they rewarded it it ended up that way
and that is correct that was not uh the
way my original submission to uh OS was
um drafted I i' just like to explain
everybody this is part of the reasons
why we're been starting late and trying
the amended language which is being sent
over is coming back different than what
we send and we're trying to catch this I
I believe that that service available to
us is just on tilt and there they're
rushing to get things done due to this
darn covid deadline and compressed
schedule that we've been had have to
work within here going on to
representative Woodcock you have your
hand up also yeah I do thank you and I'm
still on page one but that may be your
comment Mr chairman just um magnifies
the importance of representive Mile's
point that this thing is not ready for
whatever reason it should be taken at a
slower Pace that that's exactly why
we're we're walking through this right
now walking through it if you're not
going to give it a a hearing but in
either case Mr chair going back to um
the the comment that represent leakas
and cordellia made sort of uniform here
under eligibility when they're talking
about that
375% and I think I just heard it say
they could be rolled back or increased
not increase so that that money of the
two family and
64,000 or three family $81,000 limit
that could be taken out next year uh and
repeal that number as you just said and
it could be zero so it goes back to the
same issue we had last uh I don't know
was the packet bill or the cordelan
amendment lad Amendment now the allet
amendment I don't know which amendment
it was in there but where talked about
the the uh anyone could go any time but
I do want to go back and reference again
what representative L said that under
eligible student I am and and represent
Cordell you can stop me if I'm wrong
because I would heck wrong on this if I
understand this correctly I am 18 years
old 19 years old I follow into fall into
the not 21 year old category yet I fall
into the not homeschool category yet I
didn't fall into the not high school
graduate category yet and I decide that
I want to be an EFA
student and I take I sign up and I take
courses at your approved School
according to uh your approval process
and under um if I get this correct here
uh the category allows me to take it
anywhere any time which should be on
page three on the tuition the fees the
higher
education so if I'm on page three going
back to eligibility of page one I'm on
page three line four so you're with me
page three line four represent Celli I'm
still not out of high school yet and I
want to take I'm 19 years old I want to
take courses at St
Joseph and with the opportunity to bring
them back so we're going to pay the
tuition for me to go to St Joseph's
School St Joseph's College so I can take
a course there send it back course there
send it back so I could pay for my
college education we're not talking
about running start or any Community
College High School college program that
works in unison tandem I'm talking about
if I play my cards right here I can go
to College on public school money
without ever getting a high school
diploma until I get enough credits back
to say that does that is that what that
says the um that's a yes or
no I'm sorry I I'll choose the answer
the question uh without dictate as to
how I answer it um the
uh the system currently has uh dual
enrollment um running start all kinds of
um abilities for Current public school
students to take college courses
careeres uh various opportunities um and
it would be no different uh for an EFA
student so if I may follow up then so
the answer is yes I could not graduate
from high school Bel to an es become an
Esa student be 19 to 20 years old take
college credits and have the local
taxpayer pay for that under this program
a college excuse me a public school
student can take uh courses in that
manner currently I I don't know car r
quelli they can go to a college and have
the tuition paid by the local
taxpayer a public school student um is
having their uh education paid for by
the local taxpayer I cannot go to St
Joseph College and have you pay for
it the the the second part of the same
number one we've done page one
representative Woodcock I'm having a
hard time understanding where you're
going under I'm just trying I'm trying
to get page one eligibility Mr CH you
said you a page one and I keep on
hearing different answers about
different questions that's all so I'm
trying to get try to get some
clarification understanding of
concurrent and dual enrollment a student
can take uh those courses while they're
in high school leading towards their
graduation but they can also take
courses which build up and they will
receive credit for those when they are
going to College upon graduation
I representative chairman lad I
understand that but I wasn't asking
about dual enrollment I wasn't asking
about running start I was asking
specifically in this program as an Esa
student if I could take college courses
at 19 years old having not graduated
from high school I want to be an Esa
student so I go there and earn college
credits which I will eventually send
back to the high school um and so I
could get one or two years of my college
education paid for by this program that
was the question thank
you on that on that point I think one of
the reasons why we're concerned about
that Mr chairman is that in the
governor's current program in his
proposed uh project he has basically cut
money out for dual and concurrent
programs so that's a concern that we
have here thank you thank you represent
Leon um thank you Mr chair here I'm
trying to understand this question are
you talking about students who don't
have a high school diploma enrolling at
High um at some of the higher education
higher educational institutions that
don't accept students that haven't yet
graduated high
school who's
reting rep
Le U I'm sorry I sort of dropped down
back in up but no um schools will accept
at times um I know my University had
accepts students from Conan High School
um and there's no you know there's a
maybe a local Arrangement um and I think
the students have to pay to some extent
um but um they do allow that um and I
know of students who have actually been
accepted without having graduated high
school um it does happen I mean not
often but it does happen um I do know
that my institution MIT does provide
education to younger students but it's
not on a credit basis and anybody who's
been accepted is conditional upon High
School graduation to actually enroll and
get those credits so I guess I don't
quite understand the concern when it's
already set up for community colleges
and other schools where you can get that
running start and I think we're
conflating two different issues here
okay I'd like to move on now to uh
another point we we we've hammered on
this one uh can are we still on page one
or are we ready to move
on page two page two good
making progress I've got a question we
know you do go ahead okay my question is
and it's a simple one um once the once
the
distribution of the grant Mel what line
are are you on right now I'm sorry I'm
looking on line
13 okay once the transfer of the grant
is made the the the parent has been
accepted uh and uh the grant has been
given to the uh scholarship
organization at that point in time it's
my understanding that the state of New
Hampshire has no other obligation to
ensure that the student is getting an
adequate education is that
correct uh the go
ahead payments are made on a quarterly
basis um as you'll see in
um the uh progress of a student is
monitored by the scholarship
organization and we have added the
accountability measures um that we
talked about previously based on um what
we heard at the public
hearings yeah my so my so the answer to
your question is is I would assume is no
the department has no further
responsibility it really shifts that
responsibility then to the scholarship
organization representative Miler this
is very similar to a homeschooling
student only this is a different leg of
the stool it's the fourth leg the EFA so
now the student is now uh complying with
compulsory attendance requirements and
within the EFA statute you see here the
bill that student is now responsible for
submitting progress a portfolio progress
report um standardized uh Norm reference
standardized assessment data to the
scholarship organization which is then
aggregated and sent on to Department of
Education so the answer to my question
is
yes because the department all the
department does is just receive the
information
but it's it's my understanding correct
me if I'm wrong it is a scholarship
organization that's
responsible for the continuity of the
education of the EFA
student I think it's also backing off
where the parent is responsible and the
student is responsible obviously but I'm
talking from an Institutional standpoint
because I'm concerned about making sure
that there is that adequate education
being given and I'm just saying the
person who's responsible the clearly is
but the institution that monitors this
that grants the fees to the respective
education service provider is in fact
the scholarship organization that's I
just yeah I understand what you're
saying but I really don't see much
difference between this process and that
of homeschooling homeschooling you have
the same requirements in terms of the
assessment accountability side of things
and yet we're seeing amongst our
homeschoolers very very high achievement
rates so it's a program that is working
and I see no reason why this program set
up in a very similar manner wouldn't
work either yeah again I'm not talking
about quality the question is it's
either yes or no who's responsible for
that child and I assume my assumption
reading this is that it is in fact on a
primary standpoint it is a scholarship
organization not the Department of
Education go ahead I I think there is
also the question um are we looking at
uh education through the lens of
government control of a student's
education or parental control of
student's education I think we have to
put parents back in their proper place
um in uh the education of their children
as
well I don't I don't debate the role of
parents very key I'm just thinking the
institution who's responsible for the
taxpayer
dollars making sure there's an adequate
education so I'll answer the question
for me it's the scholarship organization
thank you and we can move
on thank you uh reps and Woodcock I see
you have your hand up yes sir thank you
um question if I may on line 15 of the
alled lad Amendment it wasn't in the
packet Amendment minute but it was in
this one uh you've inserted the term
approved private school can you tell me
what that means approve private school
who does the approving the Department of
Education so to follow up to that if I
am
uh uh Steve woodcock's Elementary School
for Esa
students uh and
homeschoolers they could not come to my
school are you approved by the
Department of Education um I think that
also goes to the uh uh informational
session a few weeks ago where a former
legislator was concerned about uh
students with an EFA going to schools of
terrorism I think it's a a similarly
ridiculous situation or ridiculous
question well if I may Mr chairman this
was it wasn't anything about terrorism
no ridiculous uh this is ridiculous in
my mind but beond that if I am a
religious school in the state of New
Hampshire do I have to be approved by
the Department of Education Mr quelli I
believe they are yes every religious
school is that a yes it's all that
information and the list of schools is
on the department website available for
everyone I know what schools that were
on the site thank you not all there that
should answer your question then are
there any other questions on page
two not seeing any hands One More Mr
chairman go ahead thank you on line
35 it talks 35 on page two of the uh lad
allot Amendment it talks about summer
educational
programs so if I am going to take a stem
class uh Esa would pay for that for my
child it's educational program is that
correct I would think so if I am going
to take a swimming instructional program
under the guys of physical education
would the esa pay for
that it it might be in the context of uh
what that uh class is if it's just a a
swimming class um I'm not sure if that
would qualify if I am going to take an
advanced athle atic competition class to
improve my skills would that fit under
that category as someone would do in
high school possibly no I'm talking
about summer summer school well as
someone in high school would do an
advanced physical uh um program um I
would imagine uh would be available
through a high school that would also be
available through the EFA so that means
basically I could go to summer camp
athletic Camp basketball camp I know
what you're saying and pay for that
under out of line 35 under summer
educational program ESI that's fine I'm
just trying to know what I can go to
thank
you lot of
assumptions okay uh going on to page
three no I'm still I've got a page two
question what what's your question repon
luno thank you very much Mr chair um
it's two questions and I'll I'll I'll um
just sort of be efficient and ask them
right right there but on page two line
10 the treasurer shall transfer just
wondering about the transfer authority
of funds coming out of the education
trust fund and the second part of the
question is the um the um per pupil
adequate education grant pursuant to
1984a which I know is subject of of a
lot of other bills right now including
House Bill 608 which I think we're going
to talk about later and the specific
question is how do you I guess how do
you consider the um um that that in um
in House Bill 608 specifically that that
amount of money includes um free and
reduce price lunch Equitable Grant
dollars that are not student specific
but are specific to the school district
that the student um currently
attends
currently uh the Department of Education
communicates to the treasur uh the
amount uh to be sent to school districts
it would be no different for uh the
transfer to a scholarship
organization and um currently uh the
adequacy uh Grant um formula includes
the base adequacy amount plus the uh
differentiated Aid uh categories that
are in uh statute right
now we're only dealing with what is in
statute now not what is proposed
language that minor uh might not be
signed into law okay so followup quick
followup so I'm sure then you're aware
that in
19839 the um uh monies from such fund so
this is the statute that establishes the
education trust fund monies in such fund
shall not be used for any purpose other
than to distribute adequate education
grants
to municipalities school districts and
to approve charter schools pursuant to
RSA
19842 and to provide the low and
moderate income homeowners property tax
relief program under RSA 19856 which I
actually have to jump off to and talk um
to in a few minutes and to fund
kindergarten programs as may be
determined by the general
court thank you uh further questions I'm
just saying all right
yeah further
comments okay
um we're going to move on to page three
now we have some business to do today so
page
three Mr
chair yes go ahead on line
17 it talks
about that the uh the depos the the fun
funds from the uh e
EFA uh are not taxable income according
with the IRS didn't we when we were
dealing with this question before didn't
we just determine that state
law does not uh does not
predispose IRS regulations that in fact
it's the
IRS that is the one who determines what
is taxable income am I incorrect In
remembering that when we deal dealt with
this issue
before uh I do not recall that
conversation previously but uh this
information uh this um language has been
Incorporated uh in other states in
similar programs without any uh
difficulty okay thank
you uh another question please on um
online
24 of Page Three it reads nothing in
this chapter shall be construed to
require an EFA student to be enrolled
full or part-time in either a private
school or
nonpublic online
school
so I need a clarification what does
what's that mean from a standpoint of a
child who is not going to be in a
private school or a non-online school uh
what what is the options for a student
at that point in time a totalized
totally customized education um mapped
out uh by their parents and others in
terms of uh uh online courses uh tutors
um it could be a uh teacher at a small
group instruction it could be a
homeschool Co-op uh whatever are
allowable expenses uh
um that would cover uh the education of
a child um to best meet their needs so
so on that point then representative
cordelli a person who has that kind of a
program that you just defined I would
assume when they reach the age of
matriculation age 18 they would not have
a a graduate degree or diploma is that
correct that could be the case thank
you
yes representative lakus there are a lot
of accrediting
organizations um both in the state and
nationally and there are a lot of
homeschoolers who want actually
accreditation for the classes that they
have and so they work through those
organizations they have to turn in
whatever paperwork Etc that that
organization wants and so a person could
come out with a high school uh diploma
from one of those accrediting
organizations that exist
now thank
you uh representative Le thank you thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking the
questions um just a real quick one on um
near the top of the page fees for
transportation paid to a fee for service
Transportation provider again if I set
up my own uh company to do such a thing
can I pay myself to transport my child
I I doubt whether the uh uh that kind of
situation would be approved uh depending
on the situation uh public schools now
uh pay parents to uh transport their own
children okay so it could happen Okay
and then um further down on the page and
I'm sorry I'm looking at the uh uh
earlier Amendment so I don't have the
exact line but it's close to this uh
somewhere around line uh probably 2021
22 this is on the uh um the EFA is
closed because of an intentional and
substantial misuse of funds and I
believe the word intentional has been
added here I was wondering why I believe
in the original bill it just said
substantial uh misuse of
funds um yes that was uh um a legal
suggestion that we received um uh we
have other uh suggestions that it' be uh
just uh substantial or uh just U
intentional so uh we covered both with
intentional and substantial well if it
were both it would be intentional or
substantial um in that case so here
you're you're setting the bar rather
high am I correct by saying it must be
demonstrated not just that there is
substantial misuse but that it was
intentionally misused as well correct
both both need to be met in order
unintentional
misuse um I don't think would be
something that we wanted to prosecute
someone for um but certainly um if there
is a pattern of
misuse um and it isn't intentional
that's something that uh uh should be
looked
at well like you I I don't want to
become a lawyer um but but my
understanding is that intentional is a
rather High bar to set there so anyway
that's just thank you it
helps uh any further questions on uh
page three yes my hand still raised Mr
chairman oh I'm
sorry um representative Turner and I
both have our Tanner and I both have our
hands up but I'll go men before women uh
the question that goes back to page
three which we're on
line uh four and five it's a followup to
my homeschool question before of a
youngster who's 18 homeschooled and not
graduated so that means I could not only
allow my youngster or send my youngster
to a college I could have him take the
Uber service and pay the Uber to take
them back and forth every day under that
is under that piece
right it are are you talking about
transportation to school or yes right
I'm I'm I'm trying to get clarification
on your question are you talking about
transportation to someone who's
providing an educational service yes I'm
talking about line four line four I am a
homeschooled 19-year-old non- high
school graduate attending a college and
line five we're going to have Uber take
them back and
forth is that
correct uh students uh all over the
country currently take uh taxi services
uh or bus services uh to Educational
Service uh opportunities um that is what
uh is uh being covered here
representative qu so I'm not care about
students all the United States students
all the United States AR being bankrupt
by this bill I'm just asking about this
particular line so in your your view yes
I can go to college get paid my view is
that my view is that we are looking to
cover transportation services to an
education service provider so the answer
is yes thank
you uh representative
Tanner uh thank you for taking my
question I I just want to go back to the
income tax uh question that that was
here before and and also there's there's
some other issues later on in the bill
but um
have since you think that since you
mentioned that this has been uh used in
in other states where this same bill has
come up um has there been any Court
challenges uh or do you expect Court
challenges to this
bill I do
not um representative lakus you had a
question have there been Court
challenges to in to have a followup yes
have there been Court challenges to the
income tax part of this bill not to my
knowledge not to
my representative
lakus yeah I just wanted to say somehow
in our minds we're cumulatively adding
all of these things college courses um
tuition etc etc and forgetting that
there is an upper limit and for a family
that has money and doesn't have any
other special needs it's like 3,700 and
something a parent is given a pot of
money to be distributed amongst other
things so if they spend that money to
send their child for a couple courses at
the college and transportation to get
there they aren't going to have it for
other things um that they might need to
have so it's a set pot of money it's not
breaking the the bank providing all this
huge list of things it's whatever the
parent can get with that set amount of
money thank
you thank you um further
questions uh page four then
Mr chairman follow up to that
comment okay I understand represent leas
that it is it is a limited amount of
money anywhere between $4 and $8,000
their pool I understand representative
Celli's position that parents should be
allowed to control they go but think
about the scenario here under the last
one about education summer programs I
can go to summer program buy Uber take a
basketball course and have the taxpayers
foot it that's all I'm saying the bill
allows that thank
you on page four I have a
question yes president Miler okay I'm
I'm looking at U that on on page on line
three so my presumption of the statement
about the uh
that that the parents will ensure that
an education takes place in the domains
of science mathematics language
government history Health Reading
Writing spelling history of the
Constitution of the United States and
the and New Hampshire uh
so my my sense is is that before there
was I I thought there was an indication
that you know parents can do anything
they want to but with this
language am I correct that regardless of
the approach that an EFA parent might
want to take they have to ensure that
these domains must be part of their
education am I reading that
correctly I'm not sure what you meant by
parents can do anything that they want
but um these are the core knowledge
domains um that are in the statute yes
and parallel um uh existing statute
uh so so yes thank
you um re L uh thank you Mr chair uh
just a real quick question on um we're
on page four I assume I'm sorry I had to
drop out for a minute um this is just on
the portfolio piece um that the parent
it's one of the options for the um sort
of uh assessment of academic progress um
and it states um or a teacher currently
teaching in non-public school okay um so
does that have to be an approved
non-public school or could it be any
non-public school
anything yes you would be an approved
public school yes nonpublic school so
shouldn't have the word approve maybe in
there because again we don't want them
going to the Steven Woodcock school for
um gosh gosh knows what um a good school
though it's a good
school so anyway it's just a suggestion
small point Thank You representative
Cordelia I do have I have a question on
the assessment Parts here the cons one
of the concerns I have I see that there
are three options that an EFA student
has for some sense of accountability of
the education they're
receiving but it's my
understanding that with these
assessments that a home school a
homeschool student would not be eligible
it's my understanding that homeschool
students do not have to file do not have
to file assessment reports to anyone and
that a homeschooled parent that the law
basically requires that The Homeschool
parents to keep those records personal
and they don't have to report that to
anyone am I incorrect in that that
understanding uh provisions are uh
slightly different than for a homeschool
student because they are uh different
categories of uh student but if I if I'm
a homeschool student and I seek an EFA
grant that then moves me into another
category according to this law that's
correct you you no longer are a
homeschool student you are now an EFA
student so okay so if I am a homeschool
student and I do not want to have the
and comply with these three options of
accountability then I in essence could
not become an EFA student because if I
did then I would have to submit those
reports to the scholarship organization
correct if a homeschool student and
their parents decide um that they want
to get an EA excuse me an EFA account uh
they would have to comply with these
provisions
okay thank you because we have received
as we all know we have received a few uh
emails from EF from homeschool parents
concerned about potential impact upon uh
their um ability to continue to be a
homeschool parent as well as being an
EFA but you've clarified that that in
fact they have a decision to make either
stay a homeschool or become an EFA thank
you for that clarification yes that's
one of the uh Main things we wanted to
do in this amendment um from from what
we've seen in emails and heard from
people and heard at the hearings that
was the purpose of uh putting forward
this
amendment thank
you are we on to page
five excuse me Mr chair I have a
question tan I'm sorry thank you um with
this assessment uh part if they take uh
the the um State uh test uh or any part
of it I guess are they uh part of the
Essa are are they included in Essa at
all
um for statistics
or for
whatever in in terms in terms of Essa
ESS is the um we have a state plan for
uh complying with Federal Essa law I'm
not sure what your um if they take the
Statewide assessment yes are they then
part of the Essa the the Essa statistics
that go in and uh do we have a a special
category for them or there is
uh I have not discussed with the
Department if there' be a separate
category but I I do not envision
that that would be
required okay and just another followup
on this again uh coming back to my
initial uh question where the
scholarship organization is doing all
this and we presently have two approved
scholarship organizations will there be
a brand new RFP put out so that
um we will understand who actually is
running
this
um I believe that's what I indicated
earlier so it isn't necessarily the
children's scholarship fund that we're
talking about at this
point was that a question yes yeah um
yeah there would be uh an RFP is my
understanding from the Department um and
um that's the process that would be
followed thank you on on that point
though could it be possible that there
could be two scholarship organ or
multiple scholarship organizations that
would be prepared to monitor this or is
it the intent of this law that would
there' be one scholarship organization
only I I believe the intent is that
there would be one scholarship program
one scholarship organization managing
the program thank
you uh representative Mullen thank you I
thought you might like to just talk to
somebody different for just a minute or
so representative cordelli thank you
you're quite welcome you owe me um uh so
as part of the agreement that the parent
makes uh in getting into the program
they agree that their student will not
attend their resident District full-time
that that's correct right yes um can
they I could a student take one course
what if the student wanted to take lab
science or foreign language or something
that uh the parent didn't feel that they
could provide for the student could they
do that in their in their resident high
school chemistry lab or something like
that yeah and and I heard um
representative lad say something about
um a fee a school could in fact charge a
fee if the child were not being funded
through the adequacy grant or whatever
am I am I correct in
that what are you on our curricular or
non-curricular Alicia's nodding so I'm
gonna go with Alicia
that I just I just walked in so I'm on
page four I'm just asking a question um
as part of the parental agreement it
says that you won't enroll your student
full-time so I was asking can you go
part-time is there a fee who sets up
that fee and administ administers it
does the
scholarship organization do that as
well can can I answer that okay
representative Lakers yeah this was a
question I had because my U last son was
homeschooled and he took two classes at
the high school all the time and I did
call the doe because I wanted to make
sure that children doing this could
still do that and I said and we didn't
pay anything because we pay taxes and he
said well actually the
school um is reimbursed for those
classes were we reimbursed when my son
went and that with this um the parent
would since the parent now has the state
money and that was reimbursed from the
state money at that
0.15 um the school the parent would then
reimburse the school from this for that
0.15 so it would be the amount that the
state would have paid only because the
state gave the money to the parent
already then it has to come out of the
EFA money but it's the same money that
would have gone to the school either way
no I get that what I want to know though
is um who who has to do the accounting
for this does the scholarship
organization do it or is the school
supposed to do the accounting for this
or the the school would be a service
provider and
um U would be paid from the
account okay so so my followup then to
that and I'm sorry that it's not on the
right page and you can tell me to wait
until we get to the page if you want but
how would that
interface with no government control and
no state regulations or whatever if
you're an actual Public School providing
the service
my my understanding is that that would
be an agreement between the family in
the public school in order to provide
access at a certain agreed upon
price right but on page um eight I think
representative Lon um there's that
statement about no government no ESP
will be subject to uh government control
and then right below that Roman 2
says that um I'm paraphrasing uh but
says that you the statute does not
expand the state's rights to make rules
and regulations basically around it so I
I get how it works if you're not a
government agency but I don't get how it
works if you are a government agency I
guess it comes to the matter of
voluntary participation because if you
voluntarily are working with your school
district that's not increasing their
control it's allowing you to voluntarily
enter into an agreement with a
government body and it shouldn't always
be about mandates it should be about the
fact that our government does Serve the
People and we do provide important
services and this should be Vol there
should be voluntary ways that do not
need to be be strictly laid out when you
can reach an agreement that is agreeable
to the school to the parent and to the
student to best provide it I think I'm
coming at it from a different direction
though what I want to know is is the
school subject to control what I want to
know is hey if I'm a chemistry teacher
in a public school and I've got Esa kids
can I uh sort of skirt the regulations
or uh do things differently because I
get sort of a um you know free pass on
the regulation aspect of my teaching
that's you're now an ESP yeah cuz you're
an ESP you're no longer you know what
I'm saying I uh I don't think so unless
you're talking about our other bill
which grants waivers for
Innovation ah there you go touche
representative cord
[Laughter]
Deli okay thank you very much thank you
very much representative Mullen okay
further questions represent whitcock
thank you page four U I had two question
but representative Mullen stole one uh
in the part of the accountability
represent in the amendment that the most
recent one the Alid lad amendment I
can't see the number because it's on the
screen um the one we get this afternoon
it talks about under
14 uh that the certification the review
of the assessment the authentic
assessment all those types of pieces uh
can be selected by a teacher uh by the
parent uh so basically if I understand
this right
if I am a teacher of a youngster I can
also be one selected to meet this
assessment requirement by the parent is
that correct yes okay so it's really not
a so it's like you know taking care of
your own sort like the you know who's
who's control of foresty if if I'm I'm
teaching you I'm assuming you're doing
well and I'm saying you assess it okay
so that I want to one more part of that
if I may represent that that whole piece
the requirement the assessment the
certification the parent doing this um
the teachers doing that making sure the
youngsters is on track would that not be
in conflict with the same same citation
that representative Mullen talked about
uh on page eight line 33 it says the es
students uh shall be given Max freed to
provide Ed esps provide the needs
without any government control wouldn't
that be government control telling them
that they have to this that the the
outline of our structure is telling them
that they have to do these
assessments I I don't know throughout
this entire uh Bill we've had questions
regarding accountability and I I think
these assessments back right to that
form of accountability and every one of
these four areas that we have public
school private school um uh e fa and
homeschooling there's an accountability
process laid out in
statute but my question repr L wouldn't
that be government
control uh I I think that you're looking
at the assessment which has accomplished
the way it's so stated here is uh yes it
is looking at that were we through the
compulsory attendance we're we saying
that and with State money in involved
there has to be some kind of
accountability that there is a program
occurring and that program is
effective I'm not talking about consuls
attendance for I'm talking about line
line 33 that says the provider I don't
think any wrong with it the providers
allowed maximum flexibility without
government control but it seems to me
once we St putting these standards in of
certify assessment that's government
control we're telling them what they
have to do it's just it just doesn't
make any sense you can't have it both
ways that's all so so do I take it that
you are not in favor of those
accountability
standards as regards what the one of the
after I go to college VI my Uber play
basketball and use a tax money that's a
good standard
no I didn't catch that
but
sorry yeah it says that the provider is
not um under those stand standards it
doesn't say that the parent student is
not the parent student is agreeing to
these things when they do this that's
saying the government it doesn't say the
government has control over the student
or their learning it says the government
has or not control says the government
is the provider is not being
uh having additional at any rate you
know what I mean if they at least if
they have to provide assessment that's
control telling them what they have to
assess and how to do
it representative
Mullen do you have a question thank you
um thank you for taking my question Mr
chairman um can you tell me who the um
scholarship organization answers
to who oversees like who if there was a
if I was a parent and I had a problem
with the scholarship organization
who is
is very who's Kate Baker's boss who Who
Am I who am I talking to if I have
represent cordellia you're talking with
no no no I mean if I'm a parent and I'm
I need to I need to meet with somebody
because the scholarship organization is
in my estimation doing something
inappropriately or whatever who do I who
do I go to is it the department of Ed in
in various places here both for uh
parents and providers there are appeals
process um as in current statute now uh
that allow appeals to the Department of
Education okay so it would be the
Department of Education all right thank
you
yes uh further
questions okay are we uh off of this
what page four were we on or page five
I okay see I was outside I had a call
come
in so which page are we on represent
Miler five thank
you are there any questions uh uh
referencing we've moved around one one
page necessarily maybe backed up with
another page yes but page five are there
any any
comments representative Mullen you have
your hand
up is taking it down okay thank you
represent
Woodcock you're on
mute that's probably the best way to
have me thank you representa lad I
apologize um on page five line 24 of the
most recent uh Amendment tonight's uh
lad allot Amendment the last one that
came in um on page 24 it says uh the if
I read the right right right there
section a 22 3 and 4 the intent of that
is to the scholarship organization to
provide the most non-restrictive and
efficient manner uh to pay esps is that
correct now which which line are you on
now in Rick line 22 through 26 it's the
okay it's the how I pay routine
okay so I'm assuming that they're trying
to make it simple as
possible that is that that is that the
right understanding is that if if that
was a question uh yes they're trying to
they're trying to uh um eliminate the
need for uh uh payment um out of pocket
where possible um and uh wait for
reimbursement on part of the Cent yeah
it sounds like teachers song I get that
okay so on line thank you representative
cordelli on line 23 it says but rather
uh and that goes in maximum
flexibility to the parents by
facilitating direct payments to the
esps so my question there is does that
mean the scholarship organization will
be sending the money tuition money
directly to the religious
institution religious
school if there there will be an
electronic system as I think
representative lakus mentioned before a
system called class wallet who we've
heard from in the um public hearing uh
is most likely the system electronic
system to be used and uh the uh
religious school or non-religious school
would be a service provider and be in
that system and be paid uh via that
system for the tuition fees for the
student okay so just to follow up your
comment repr Kelly I wasn't questioning
how it did that I understood that what
represent leas made very clear before
that system so but the bottom line is
the simple layman's term is the money is
going from the organization to the
religious school to the not not from not
from the organization the service
provider service provider State service
provider religious school is that
correct that the
Train the this State funds get to put
into the account the account is directed
by the parent in this case to the uh
school for payment of tuition this says
direct payments from the the service
facilitating direct payments to the es
provider doesn't say from the parent
it's the scholarship organization
doesn't say the parent this is bypass
the parent there's the whole
purpose thank you there they are
preapproved programs
so not suggesting they're not valid not
pre-approved represent I'm just saying
the money in simple lay terms is going
from the esa to the provider to the
religious school that's all represent
like
us yeah my understanding is that it's
sort of like having an EBT card um as
the parent you're actually using the
card the money is and it goes through
that it goes through that service
provider but it is the parent who's
using the card so it's the parent who's
paying just like if you paid let's say
you paid with a Visa card you're paying
but there's service interactions that go
on in between and your money goes from
here to there whatever but you're the
one it's always considered that you're
the one who's who's making the charge
right or with an EBT card you're the one
who's making the charge to the grocery
store and that's this the parents are
using the card and making the payment to
the school but it goes through the E the
um electronic service provider there's a
fee and whatever there you know just
like when you use your credit card and
the money gets moved around that's how
it works I understand that represent
Lakers thank you but what this says what
this says is the money goes directly
from the service Prov from the ESL from
the state the service provider granted
the parents said it's okay to the
private school the religious school so
the money is going directly there even
though the parent okay it that's what it
says thank you representative Tanner um
thank you uh this was uh a question I
think I asked the the people with the
card uh before about uh
pre-approval and also about competition
to get the cheapest amount for I used an
example I think of literary book but um
again who makes the pre-approval of uh
these expenses is it the scholarship
organization the card company is there
any conflict of interest Clause
there those are some of the questions I
have about
that it's h you know who approves the
preapproved
the the um service providers are um
entered into the system into in this
case probably the class wallet system um
by the uh scholarship
organization um based on uh requests
from the parent that uh um we're going
to be sending a little Joey to the uh U
well in this case not the Woodcock
school but maybe the mafit school which
has been approved by the
department probably a better choice I
ask what I'm talking about is the
pre-approval of the individ of the you
know let's say um they go to the mfet
school and uh they want to they want to
purchase a a book to read for creative
writing or something
is the is the mafit school the people
that pre-approve it is the scholarship
company the one that that pre-approve it
is the parent the one that pre-approves
it and is there any conflict of interest
Clause there I did ask about this
because there was concern um parents
very often homeschooled parents like to
buy used books from other homeschool
parents and I did call and ask was that
something that would be allowed and they
said that um what would happen is that
the parent who wanted to sell The Used
Books would just contact the uh
scholarship organization and the
scholarship organization would approve
um them for selling those used books to
those other parents does that answer
your question just like you're a
University Bookstore is there a conflict
of interest uh Clause anywhere here does
anybody see a conflict of interest
with with the with the school selling
the student um a book um isn't that what
happens in bookstores all the time no
with the
preapproval and and the fact that what
they can buy and what they can't
bookstores don't tell you what you can't
buy and
what uh all uh expenses are tracked in
the system by a category uh category
being uh the type of uh educational
material that is being purchased or the
service that's being purchased so you
could uh you know if you want to find
out how many number two pencils were
purchased versus number three pencils uh
you could do
that
really from whom do you you find that
out uh there are many reports standard
within the system that will be available
to uh both the scholarship organization
and the department
representa Le do you have a question uh
actually I do thank you um so I'm just
interested in just a couple of quick
questions that just came up based on
this so am I correct in understanding
then that if we're using the class
wallet system um the parent receives the
money from the state via the scholarship
organization okay so that's now in the
EFA um 10% or up to 10% % can be um kept
by the scholarship organization okay and
now did I hear that the card company can
also take some money off uh you know
transaction fees is that is that true is
that as well and that would come from
the EFA as
well I I believe that that's part of the
um fees that would be charged uh from
the class wallet system to the uh
scholarship organization and come from
their admin
would be paid then by the scholarship
organization I see okay um and and then
just really quick on the second thing
was there was something about um a um
homeschooling parent who wants to sell
their used books to another
homeschooling parent and the first the
one who wants to sell them needs to be
approved um by the scholarship
organization as you know legitimate um
what if you want to buy your books from
Barnes and Noble do they need to be
approved uh yes they could be in the in
the uh system as a service provider okay
okay thank you that's
it represent Miler thank you Mr chair
I've got two
questions one of one of the concerns
that we we have is
that the experience of Florida
Arizona Ohio Indiana
Pennsylvania these types of programs
have been fraught with
fraud and uh these states I'm assuming
have uh learned from their
mistakes uh with the fraudulent actions
to taken place by some of the
participants in these programs so my
first question deals with are you
convinced that the items that you have
mentioned here in this particular
section of the law would limit fraud
from those
participants I would take exception to
your comments about about the
substantial fraud in those locations um
we did have testimony um about Arizona
during the public hearing from um a
fraudulent lobbyist um who did not uh
give his uh full background um who
mischaracterized uh things that had gone
on in Arizona where um possibly uh 1% of
the uh money was uh
categorized as misused as per an audit
and that is one reason why Arizona has
um provided more administrative uh fees
to their Department to run the operation
and have uh uh begun implementing the
class wallet system that we are talking
about
here well your your information my
information differ because there has
been in fact fraud and there's been laot
there's been uh uh
changes in the law as a result of that
to protect that that's answer you
answered my first question to me it
still is a question second question is
please uh outline for me what happens in
paragraph three uh Roman numero 3 here
that deals with a um special ed parent
who wants to use uh an an EFA account
and what happens to the rights the
federal and state rights of a Disabled
Student a special education student Etc
if I choose as a parent to come into the
EFA
program uh what happens to those rights
from a state and federal standpoint that
I have under a public education
system we've heard many times um from
people uh that I think wrongly U Mis
misstate that um uh parents uh lose
their idea Pro protections when they
withdraw their child from a public
school uh there are in fact
idea uh Federal Regulations involved in
placing a student in a private school
it's parental placement in private
school statutes and I'd be glad to
provide you um copies of the law
regarding that in which um the uh Lea
the um the private school and the parent
get together and come up with a service
plan and that uh a
percentage proportional uh percentage of
the federal idea funds that go to that
uh
Lea um would be provided to the uh uh
private school for use in the service
plan for that child that is developed so
are you excuse me sorry that's okay um
so for instance if there were uh 10
students um in that Lea with
disabilities one was placed by um a
parent in a private school uh on10th of
the federal monies that go to the um
District um would be provided to the uh
to pay for the service plan in that
private
school if if my child just a just a
followup if my child had an
IEP and chose to go to another school my
presumption then and correct me if I'm
wrong my presumption is is that the
local school district then does not have
a
responsibility of going and implementing
the IEP that would be the new school
uh unlike charter schools for example
where the resident school district is
responsible for that IEP in this
instance the new school the new service
provider if you may they would be
responsible for whatever the parent and
that service provider would uh develop
for the uh special needs of that
particular student is that
correct the parent um as we heard in
testimony from I think it was the lady
in from Arizona um who has an Esa and uh
a child with disabilities uh yes they U
worked out with uh different service
providers for the best uh Services uh
they could find for their child with
disabilities um and paid for it with
their um Esa you know including uh any
kind of therapies or special tutors Etc
that the parent might feel appropriate
so the so the answer is my question was
the local school district does not have
any responsibility for that
child e the the IEP when they leave the
school district with the EFA is that's
correct right yes thank you that's what
my question
was I might add to represent Myer that
in developing a service plan part of
that idea money that's used for
developing service plans and looking to
help kids which are not in the regular
school but have IEPs is reserved by the
department it's not that much money but
it is available to assist kids in uh
attaining their IEPs through as we've
talked here through a e service
provider if I could just ask um um the
uh subject of uh Audits and so forth I'd
be interested representative miler in
those um information on those audits
that you
cited absolutely I read about it and I
can tell you that that's what that there
was fraud in those States big
time I'd be glad to see that thank you
sure yeah I'll give you the reference to
it
absolutely
represent oh wake
up you're on mute
I'm okay I'm sorry I forgot to take my
hand down that was my fault sorry I'm
sorry to wake you up no I'm not I'm
paying
attention my head gets heavy though
that's aome
okaying okay are we done with page five
can we represent luno yeah so I no I'm
I'm sorry I was sort of jumping ahead to
page six but it was tied right in with
this question we'll go to we'll go to
page
six
so so thank you very much Mr chair so so
um sort of following on On
representative Myer's question with
regards to um to uh being able to detect
substantial misuse of the funds I I was
just wondering how adding um the
requirement to prove that it was
intentional how that um how that's
proven and how that helps to uh far it
out
fraud
was intentional and substantial
misuse are are you asking for what
intentional means no I I know what
intentional means but but um you know
this is this is going to turn into a law
so so obviously intentional is something
that would have to be proven and so I'm
referring to page six line7 and this is
specifically as it results I mean as it
relates to the misuse of funds which
which I think is what representative
Miler was talking about so so in this
amendment the word in the words
intentional and were were added as an
additional um uh hurdle uh in in in
determining or improving substantial
misuse of funds so I was just wondering
what what um what prompted that
additional hurdle to make it a little
bit harder or maybe a lot harder to uh
to determine
fraud
a
uh uh legal advice uh suggested uh the
word
intentional for what
purpose for for what for what I'm sorry
for what purpose uh uh basically that uh
uh an
unintentional uh charge of uh an exp
um would not uh facilitate contacting
the Attorney General's office um you
we're looking for intentional uh misuse
um just like with um a uh uh School
District in uh my County um that uh
mischarged uh the federal government for
a lunch program for a number of years um
uh was investigated but the uh um I'm
not sure if it was deemed unintentional
but uh was not fined uh by the uh
federal government um so I think
intentional is um a key um insertion
here did your just a followup on that
did your did your attorney give you a a
um legal basis for proving
intent uh they did not um but I'm sure
you could um you know help us and find
an attorney that would give us that
legal
basis uh going on to representa
Tanner thank you um is there any penalty
other than they just don't get the
EFA anymore for intentional and sub
substantial uh misuse of funds is there
any any penalty have to repay the
fund there is a provision for referral
to the department and to the Attorney
General's
office and they would make the
determination as to what the penalty was
I mean in other pieces of legislation we
have you know um that it's a felony for
certain things or um you know we've
actually put in fines
um and all I see in here is that they
lose their EFA I I think that they would
be uh the Attorney General's office
would be capable of determining what the
uh charge and offense would
be and I I believe that's alluded to on
lines 26 and
who
process which is process but when you're
talking about a fraudulent use once the
Attorney General knows that there are
consequences uh next question from
uh let's go back to representative
Woodcock are you're next representative
Le I haven't forgotten you out there no
that's
fine thank you um representative lad uh
just two clarifications simply one on
the intentional and substantial area uh
if it was uh an unintentional error uh
and I don't know what you determine
substantial is but I make an
unintentional error of of $750
$1,000 and is there is there a way
requirement that that be paid back I
didn't do it intentionally but I don't
want to get thrown out the program but I
made it I made a purchase error of$
thousand wrong is what's what's the
process
there I am uh
sure that that would be adjusted through
the class wallet system and that that's
in the in this law I didn't see
it that that that's stated in this law I
didn't see that that's why I
asked representative Woodcock we've had
a number of situations uh and the one
that represent cordelli alluded to was
the Medicaid in schools and how uh
school districts were
misinterpreting uh how to assess the
need for this and they were billing and
the billing had not been uh recommended
by a person qualified to make that
determination as you may recall I think
all school districts were caught up in
this and of course the the concern was
primarily that of the department uh that
if they allowed this to continue then we
could lose other Federal grant monies uh
so that it was corrected by uh rebaking
the rules with working with health and
human services and uh we're now on
smooth territory that's been fixed
nobody had to end up paying money we we
continued forward so I I would hope that
most of these activities would be
rectified in a manner similar to what
we've had experience in the public
schools with okay and the last the last
question on this page for me if I may Mr
chairman on line 13 um when they're
talking about the a minimum of minimum
of random uh independent audits Rick do
we know if random minimum is is like one
annually or five what historically what
do they do in the other the other areas
what what is that number is a
substantial number or it's just free
floating it's an annual audit you'll see
in the next line down on the number how
many random audits that's the question
what's the what does minimum mean one
five 10 100 what does it mean who
determines it who determines it thank
you what what is it what's the
number are you asking about random
audits
um I'm ask I'm asking a line 13
represented page six when it says Min
minimum number I'm just asking sh a
minimum that's the minimum requirement
not a minimum number it's a minimum
requirement that they conduct random
audits understand that minimum
requirement they conduct random audits
my question is how many random audits do
they do at least one
annually
one one out of all these potential
thousands of students that may take
thisam an Ann an annual audit annually
is the minimum
requirement one out of thousands thank
you one I'm not sure what you mean by
one out of thousands um if I can address
this from a data management point of
view the minimum number would depend
based upon the complexity this isn't
something we can put in statute if
there's a more complexity to it the
minimum number to audit would be higher
than if everything was very simple and
straightforward this is going to depend
upon the level of data and this isn't
something we can foresee at this time
thank
you uh ref Le thank you Mr chairman um
just as a point I disagree with the
prior statement the the law could easily
State 20% of all EFA shall be audited on
a randomized basis every year there's
nothing to prevent that right now the
way I read this and I again I'll follow
on following on representative Woodcock
shall at a minimum conduct random
independent audits it does not State how
many the scholarship or is it correct
the scholarship organization could
conclude that they meet that requirement
by auditing one EFA per
year we have the issue of garbage in
garbage out if you mandate a minimum
number
I um you have your hand uper my time to
representative Leon represent up thank
you go ahead thank you as as an
economist and as a data analyst this is
something that you could specify that
but that does not mean that it is
Meaningful or useful information this is
something that would come through the
general oversight of it in the RFP where
they could look to this and spell it out
based upon the actual data that they are
that they are facing this is not
something that can reasonably be
mandated at this
point I'm sorry I I missed all that I my
internet just cut out all I heard was
something mandated at this point what I
said is that as an economist and as a
data analyst I know that you can set a
set a certain level prescriptively but
that does not mean that it is useful
information this is something that in
the RFP process it can be better
addressed than we can do here today I'm
react to this if you if you look down on
the top of page seven in regard to all
this the board sh of Education shall
adopt rules pursuant to RSA 541a
relative to the EFA program the
scholarship organization May adapt rules
or procedures that are necessary for the
administration of this chapter and this
is a Roman numeral uh 16 in that chapter
this may include guidel
procedures so it looks like there's the
ability to develop once we know for
example that there's X number it's just
like if we're going to do a survey of
our faulty buildings in this state we're
not going to put down we're going to
have to do a random you know of of 10 or
so we got to First find out how many are
faulty and and then on you go before you
go represent LE right I I I I understand
what you're saying here but this is
public money that is being utilized and
as a taxpayer I want to know where the
public money is going and if there is no
requirement here and right now I do not
see anything other than an absolutely
minimal
requirement for auditing any efas and by
the way I also don't see any requirement
for the auditing of the scholarship
organization either um you're basically
giving away potentially giving away
public
monies well I think that in regard to
for example what I've mentioned at
several hearings already
that there are many doe2 forms which are
submitted that are audited but there's a
number that aren't and I I I think if
you were to ask folks over the
Department of Education would it be wise
for these all to be audited they say yes
but right now there's a number of errors
that can come in and perhaps we all have
the same requirement that you're
speaking to here for the public schools
as well when they're submitting their
annual
reports they also are audited by the
fact that they report to public bodies
including their their school boards and
the fact that they report to their
voters as well whereas in this case
there is no such reporting and wouldn't
it be nice if they reported to parents
as well parents are
voters representa
Tanner thank you um I guess I have uh
two two questions on this one would be
so what is best practice as far as
setting up audits uh the number of
random audits considering that we'll
have uh we have an approximation of
students that could possibly be um
eligible for this number one and second
of all who's going to write the new
RFP uh for the for this scholarship
organization what page is that
on well it was mentioned by uh
representative Lon that
um the number of audits and and the
procedure and you you spoke to the fact
that the uh scholarship fund was going
to set up rules and
regulations um I'm and she mentioned
that it would be in the RFP I'm just
wondering who is in charge of making up
the
RFP um and what would be the best
practices uh from a risk management or
data analyst point of view uh for audits
the number of random
audits um that is a question best about
best practices I'm not sure how many
statisticians we have on this committee
but I believe that this is the sort of
thing that should be handled through the
guidelines that are already provided for
in this bill because that falls better
under the Department of
Education okay next individual uh
representative
Tanner she or represent Miler uh thank
you Mr chairman I just want to point a
clarification before we go on in the
meantime I've been doing some checking
on the issue of special
education and I have found that the
federal idea money can only be used for
students in public schools not in this
program progam cannot leave Public
Schools they have to if they want to
take advantage of the I idea money it's
only in public education Public Schools
thank
you representative uh Lakers you got
your hand up we go
um yes but children right now get um
Services Etc provided by private schools
and so that would still be something a
parent would negotiate but the other
part I was going to comment on was that
we we legislators pass laws all the time
and they're generally open because we
can't foresee all the things so we make
them General and then whoever is
enacting them makes the rules and the
rules go before Jael car Etc and so in
this case we the rules will come after
this we're putting the policy the
general guidelines and then the State
Board of Education will adopt rules the
scholarship organization May adopt
guidelines or procedures but we're still
having oversight of this by the um
Department of Education which if you
think
about at least the commissioner is
appointed by an elected official so it's
still just like a superintendent is
appointed by an elected
official represent
cordelli yes in terms of uh re Myer's
question about um uh the use of funds
um uh
quoting um children enrolled in a
private school by
parents um let me see if I can find the
right
section uh amounts to be expended for
the provision of these
services including Direct Services to a
parentally placed private school
children by the educational agency shall
be equal to the proportionate amount of
federal funds May available under this
chapter in calculating a proportionate
amount of federal funds the local
Education
Agency um shall go through a child fly
process to make sure that they know how
many uh children with disabilities are
in the Lea and then uh divide the um
number by the total amount of federal
funds to uh come up with a per student
basis and that's the amount of money
that would go to the um to the uh
provision of services in the private
school um and I'll be glad to send you
uh the statutes
further qu comments representa
Le sorry I had my hand up from before
sorry I keep forgetting to do that I'm
sorry okay we are now on on what page
what seven seven yeah any further
questions on page seven let's move on oh
yes yes oh yes represent Miler yeah you
have the whole issue of uh we've talked
about this before and that's uh uh on
line
um we talk about
discrimination and um we have issues
with that
obviously we don't believe that public
monies should be used for
indiscriminating in
institutions and that's a pro we we
believe that's a problem I guess the
makers of this uh proposal of this
amendment don't feel that's that's a
really un important thing we do we don't
think any child should be discriminated
against and I've used the example I
think of the tri Tri State Tri State
Christian
Academy that basically excluded a
student after being in in their school
for for 11 years became transgender and
was basically eliminated from that
school
now that's private money I understand
that but if we're going to have public
money being used for this then I and I
have strongly strong concerns about
potential
discrimination uh in this uh in this
bill for students who may want to have a
Christian EX in that example may have a
Christian education but may be
gay uh and I think that's unfortunate
that this particular
Bill allows that to happen to
discriminate against students of that
nature I'm sorry that was a statement I
shouldn't have made a statement that was
a not a question and if I may I would
like to remind the committee about the
gleon study that showed that there is a
lower rate of bullying harassment and
violence against gay and transgendered
students in private schools including
religious private schools than occurs in
the public schools this is an issue
where where within the those Christian
World Views and those private schools a
lot of these children are able to find a
safe space that they did not have in
their local public
school if I could Mr chair thank you
very much represent cordelli thank you
um yes in that I checked a little bit
into that situation that representative
Miler U mentioned and it's my
understanding that that was a a mutually
agreeable decision that the child would
leave that school and in terms of
discrimination um I wish that public
schools did not discriminate they
discriminate against based on
wealth uh uh I don't think that uh there
are a lot of families in Manchester who
could afford to move to Bedford to get a
better education for their child uh they
discriminate based on zip code I'm sure
that there are children uh in tofen Boro
that would like to go to the molten Boro
Academy it might even be near near to
their house but they can't because they
are in their WR zip code and isn't it a
shame that in America children who um
are in a a poor uh school district and
their parents um maybe use their parents
add their grandparents address so that
their kid can go into a better school
have been sentenced to jail for trying
to get a better education for their
child I think that's unconscionable and
the system has to change to allow
parents to find the best education for
their child uh the family that I've been
working with based on
bullying they were granted manifest
education hardship and said go find
another public school for your child two
Public Schools turn down that child now
is it because they had an IEP maybe but
they would rejected from those Public
Schools um so you know I don't want to
hear that public school do not
discriminate what about public schools
that cannot accommodate a child Cal down
I'm sorry this is important to me it is
to me too yeah I know I'm not gonna
start shouting at you I wish it was
important to everybody calm down no we
do have I apologize Mr chair
for statement rather than a question uh
I'll wait for my emotion when we get
into the debate I
apologize I do as well Mr
chairman
okay thank you very much to both of you
um let's get on with the business of
trying to Wade through this uh represent
Ellison uh thank you Mr chairman I I I
just have one question and I I raised it
earlier and I'm still a little unclear
but it appears to me that there's a
clear conflict between state and federal
non-discrimination laws and section 194
e417 which allows educational providers
to discriminate based on religious-based
policies seems to me those two things
are in direct conflict and I if anybody
has any further information on that
conflict uh I I I would appreciate
hearing
it thank
you representative
uh are which page are we on still seven
eight eight page eight yeah I flipped
mine
over
page
seven page eight you have questions on
seven are there any P questions on page
seven yes sir yes Mr chairman my hands
up okay go for it thank you um the I
understand from I couldn't tell which
representative was speaking because
they're not identified on the screen
except for the ones we can see but the
the question wasn't the the public
schools and the pral schools
um allowing bullying obviously they
don't um it occurs we know that um nor
where it is better the question
regarding lines 14 through 18 is the
ability for my youngster to access a
school if they are knowingly gay or
lesbian when they apply if in fact that
school does not allow them to go there
uh and we had the Christian Schools just
the other day from pora say they would
not allow them um in dialogue so it's
which is fine I'm just saying but that's
public money saying they can't go there
that's discriminatory practice um and as
we that's that's the issue of getting of
the schools themselves not allowing
youngsters in there and as regards the
molor tubor Earl I would think
representative cordelli could fix
that thank you represent Tanner uh thank
you um when it mentions in this uh about
the scholarship organization shall not
exclude discriminate um are we talking
about um New Hampshire's discrimination
laws or the federal discrimination laws
because I think sometimes they get
confused the federal discrimin
discrimination laws are not as um
detailed as the as the state
discrimination laws are and I would like
to know uh who abides by which
non-discrimination laws in between the
scholarship
organization the um schools that are
providing these Educational Services and
um I guess like the the card
company anybody have an answer to
that I would I would think that all all
students in and they're taking uh uh
having receiving an education
opportunity in this state would be
obligated to follow both federal and
state legislation or
statute I I would just indicate also um
if I mind that um the religious
character of an organization um is
Central um to religious freedoms in the
country as as ruled by the Supreme
Court and when we look certain statutes
within uh State Statute there are
exemptions for religious institutions in
terms of housing preferential treatment
there um as we we recall when we looked
at some of this uh language last year
when we were looking at um uh other
changes needed to incorporate education
as uh part of of of discrimination in
our
laws representative
leay thank you uh I'll be right
there um yeah just a couple of things
these are just back to the sort of
financial pieces here um and I'm on page
seven but again I'm looking at the uh
morning's Amendment so my lines may be
off by just a couple of lines um so uh
we see on number uh 16 uh Roman numeral
16 scholarship organization May adopt
guidelines of procedures um these may
include requiring a shity bond for
education servic providers receiving
more than a
100,000
um would there be a reason not to
require aurity Bond because assurity
bond would I mean serve some very
positive purposes I think um so would it
not make more sense that over a certain
threshold there must be a shity
[Music]
bond excuse me what page were you on
there represent page seven page seven
I'm sorry page seven so Roman numeral 16
I believe it is in page seven line
12 12 oh line 12 okay yeah yeah sure
yeah line 12 so it's about the shity
bond and it just says for over a 100,000
that they may require a shity bond and
I'm just suggest I'm wondering why would
we say may if we have a threshold um the
shity bond ures certain things
particularly for the um the student and
the parent um that the contract is
honored and if not that there means of
recovery um Would we not would it not
perhaps be better to require a shity
bond rather than just simply
maybe that's
all um and I don't know if you need to
answer that it's more a suggestion I
suppose than anything else um a second
uh point is on Roman numeral 14 just
above that a little bit above that and
I've I've addressed this before and I
just wanted to again um the scholarship
organization can receive and expend
gifts grants and donations of any kind
from any public or private entity to to
carry out the purposes of this chapter
so what would be the things that this
scholarship organization could spend the
money
on could it include for example in some
way Distributing these gifts grants Etc
to um participants in the EFA
program no um
uh um individual contribution or uh
deposits into the EFA account by the
parent or or others um is prohibited in
the
statute so what would be of so I guess
all I'm just trying to drive out here is
if if the scholarship organization
receives these gifts grants from
whatever entities what would they expend
the money on then what would they do
with the funds then would it be to defay
costs of the scholarship organization or
represent exactly you you've got it
right there that 10% might become 6% or
3% or nothing if they get enough
scholarship grants yes it also increase
the compensation of those running the
organization yes the answer is of course
so okay thank
you any anything else on page
seven
any
comments
move move onight okay page
nine any comments on page
nine page 10 quick page
10 uh represent
Tanner thank you on on page nine I I
don't know if I have the exact uh
amendment that we're on but at least in
the original bill I believe um the legal
proceedings down at the bottom and again
uh there's a no liability Clause uh not
limited but no liability clause for the
scholarship
organization um and also uh saying that
legal uh challenges are um restricted in
certain ways in this particular uh
section and I was just
wondering um just as I was with the
income question whether those will meet
uh legal challenges and whether they in
fact have been approved by a lawyer that
they they actually are constitutional
and legal to do
that I if I mind I I believe that um
that language has been reviewed um
actually um I think we had testimon from
The Institute from justice during the
hearing and I believe that they have
reviewed that
language and and as a followup have
there been any legal challenges or court
cases to your knowledge uh since this is
uh um legislation that's been across the
country on these particular
issues I'm not sure if this exact
language has been uh um implemented
Across the Nation but uh there are no
legal challenges that I'm aware
of thank you uh we're going to go back
to page 10 that that question was from
page uh excuse back to page nine that
was from uh page 10 are there any
questions on page
nine represent Woodcock yeah thank you
represent chair represent lad you you
jumped those seven so quickly I couldn't
get my finger on the uh the hand up
button I do have one question if I may
just allow for a definition on page
seven page eight please
page eight yeah I I just I missed the
record you went over so quickly I
couldn't get there okay just tell us the
line number please 33 33 and
34 I'm just curious I'm curious again
what that means without government
control what does that sentence mean 33
and
34 um are you uh using the new amended
version or are you on I'm on these I
think the the one that came under your
name uh represent not the one that came
on my a little while ago so page eight
lines 33 and
34 on my version it talked about the
provider getting free from government
control I'm curious what that what that
actually means definition Roman numeral
2 I think is the okay you must be
talking 31 down through you know part of
that page down to
35 or or even 37 I'm sorry I'm looking
at the new one that came to South
afternoon for you and represent of valid
line 34 and 35 you're right
okay what does that actually
mean I mean I read it it basically says
to me they can do anything they want but
I don't know what that means legally or
what the intent of it is to
mean
do you have a response for that
represent
cordelli I believe that the uh intent
there is uh uh
especially we anticipate there going to
be a lot of small um independent uh
service
providers um maybe teachers uh group
educating a group of uh students and um
we want to make sure that they
have the uh ability to um provide the uh
contracted for
services um we don't want to get into uh
an over regulation um situation with
them uh the parents are going to uh um
hire those uh service
providers um we don't want to have to
get into a waiver
situation follow up Mr chair
yes okay thank you represent Kelly
earlier in our dialogue you mentioned
that esps had to be approved by the
Department of Education we went through
that long list of schools and providers
so you telling me just now that a couple
teachers could get together and that
that would
count uh a couple of teachers can get
together a couple of teachers can get
together now in former Charter School
well we're not talking about Charter
School you already have that we're
talking which working great talking
about right now this bill that talks
about you just said three or four
teachers can get together and so they
don't have the regulation I'm just
asking a little while earlier you said
that they had to be approved by the doe
to be a service provider I'm just asking
which one is the right
one um I'm not sure I'm not sure what
you're getting at with that question um
service providers are added to the
system by the scholarship
organization um at the uh request of
parents who want to uh uh have that uh
provider um provide services to their
child or um meet an expense
requirement I'm not sure what you're uh
if I might I think what represent
representative wock are you referencing
the the statement earlier that private
schools can have to be on an approved
list that's a I was but when he just
said three or four could get together as
a group and work with a student students
and they wouldn't have any control why
wouldn't that be a group uh to be
approved that's all I'm just just seems
to be half six one half a dozen another
that's all I see thank you thank you for
the clarity Mr
Le thank you represent lad thank you
very much um I I'm more inclined to read
that a little bit differently I would
say that it in terms of private schools
who do not receive Government funding or
state funding they don't and they take a
student that has an EFA they're not
going to be bound by the Department of
Education rulings or uh government
rulings that are that uh are not really
applicable to the private
school um there's a certain degree of
Independence in a private school and
they remain not taking Federal money or
state money simply because they're
trying to maintain that
Independence that that's that's how I
read it thank would sorry um going on um
to the page nine we had dis we had
um discussed I I believe we went to page
10 and did the stuff on the uh liability
of the legal proceedings are there any
questions
regarding uh anything on page nine Mr
chair my hand is has been up I've been
trying to flag you
down okay hi go ahead represent Mullen
thank you nice to see you again um so um
representative cordelli I'm sure that um
you are probably like me getting lots of
correspondence from individuals in the
state regarding this bill um it is not
lost on me that in the past half hour or
so we have talked about two places in
the Bill where safeguards are put in
place to protect the service providers
from discriminatory behavior um one
being the point that uh representative
Ellison referenced and the other one
representative Woodcock I think um did
you at any point in time think about
putting any language into the bill that
would offer some sort of protection to
kids and Families
I mean I know I I I I get your PO point
on the fact that federal and state
non-discrimination laws
exist but clearly somebody thought it
was important enough to protect the
service providers that it's it happens
twice in in the bill um I'm just
wondering whether or not you in fact did
think about putting something in or
whether or not it was just deemed
unnecessary uh I think I would go back
to the uh uh title of the bill education
Freedom
accounts that applies directly to
parents um and that they have the uh
ability through this bill to uh find the
best education opportunities for their
children um I'm not sure what
protections um you're thinking that they
might
require um
discriminatory protection I I I'm I'm
referencing specifically the
discriminatory Clauses for service
providers in terms of the children being
discriminated against is that yeah yeah
or the
families I I I think that
uh parents are going to look for the
appropriate and best education
opportunities for their child if that's
in a school or some other um combination
of services uh that's what they're going
to look for um you
know just with a a child who is uh being
bullied in a private school they're
going to ex be in a public school uh
they're going to want to find uh the uh
a better education uh service op oity
for their child um and that's difficult
for them at this
point uh okay thank
you further questions Mr chairman yes
just to follow up to representative
mullen's question repr Celli so is there
embedded anywhere in this bill
protections for
youngsters protections for youngsters uh
as we talk about discriminatory practice
not Parents Choice not the provider the
providers the organizations here the
government organizations The Profit
making businesses the nonprofits they're
well covered they're they're they're
legally free there's no liability I'm
just talking about for students is there
anything embedded in this bill that
talks about protecting kids so so for
instance the uh two girl school that
representative mfet discussed during our
uh public hearing um are you suggesting
that you want uh protections um for a a
young lad who might want to attend one
of those schools well if you're talking
about transgender child repr Cordell I'm
not talking about that specifically I'm
talking about any any youngster in the
school has any safeguards I I see a bill
that's that doesn't incorporate the key
element which is youngsters there's no
safeguards in here every all the
protections for the businesses and the
operations that's all I'm asking you if
you put any in or you didn't I mean I'm
I'm not really sure this is even your
bill the way I read it you keep
answering generalities I'm just asking
is there anywhere in there about kids
protecting kids that's all I don't see
any just tell me line just tell me what
line so I can see it I I don't think we
have to put everything into a statute
that's uh already in-law that the parent
the guardian who has custody of the
child has the right to bring uh forward
any kind of issue and use our judicial
system to get resolved that is always
open and available thank you Mr
chairman thank
you was there anything that's left on
um on page
10 are we down to the the bottom right
now okay oh your hands W represent Luna
thank you very much Mr chair um on page
10 I'm referring
to let's see um lines um um six through
nine and U and I guess my first question
is does this mean an education savings
account is an educational service in
itself
do you understand my question would you
please explain it a little bit further
sure so so it says on on on line eight a
pupil enrolled in an education Freedom
account program uh persuant to
194e is therefore exempt from this
requirement this requirement being 193
colon one so my question is wa well
little bit of context 193 one basically
is the compulsory attendance requirement
if you're not attending your local
public school district you're
attending it's okay as long as you're
attending a school district outside of
your a public school outside of your
District or a public or private school
um um um accredited in this state or
another state charter school home school
things like that luno may us repres luno
may US ask one you on the which
amendment are you on by May it's rough I
can't follow you I'm on oh so I may have
given you bad line number so it's the
same language sorry you to face the page
right yes so yeah line sorry it's
section three lines 18 through 21
represent can you respond to that please
H yes thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative luno this is the
portion that creates the education
Freedom account as a separate
educational option from private public
public or homeschooling this shows the
fact that this is an educational out um
educational educational Choice um where
the funding comes from the public but it
is directed according to this new law
that is being created without this
inclusion in 1931 this would be an
educational program without a home and
it would cause cause a lot of confusion
this is this is simply an implementation
that shows that this is one the fourth
me method of attending school public
private home or EFA so follow up on that
yes but but isn't having an
EFA used isn't that used to pay for
attending public private
homeschool um is isn't that what it's
supposed to be used for so you know
you're you're you're sort of being
circular here that that that now it's
how you pay for your
education um satisfies your compulsory I
I I don't understand how how how the the
manner with which you pay for Education
somehow satisfies uh a compulsory
attendance requirement represent LE can
you respond to that please yes thank you
Mr chair this is spelled out as to how
the education is delivered at the
direction of the parent regardless of
whether they purchase it from public
private or all C options this is an
education that falls upon the parent
according to the agreement signed with
the scholarship organization and while
it may end up looking a lot like public
school private school or homeschooling
it is a separate way of educating a
student so the freedom account is its
own way of educating a student is what
you're saying
yes it's like a financial instrument to
me yeah
wow wow I guess
I know all about financial instruments
this is actually an educational one that
allows the the choice of educational
service providers which can include I
know a great deal about financial
implications or financial instruments
that have social implications as well
and this one do y I also have a
concentration in course 14
so very nice I didn't take the extra
four classes to get a math double major
though don't know where you
are thank you very much okay representa
Tanner
your your hand down represent luno or
you've got another question uh no my
hands
down uh thank you Mr chair and um I your
last statement about um you know parents
uh having the ability through the courts
Etc to uh have their oversight of this
um particular
program when you when you put a no
liability clause in no liability shall
arise from the scholarship or the state
or public school or School District
based on the award or use of an EFA
doesn't that take away uh the ability of
parents um and the ability of a citizen
actually who feels that they need some
sort of redress to go through um legal
means I'm not not an attorney but I
don't think you're
ever free of something coming at you and
I think if there's something where
there's and not not an attorney but
there's gross negligence or issues which
are Beyond uh I think you're always open
to answer to the law and and uh and to
be liable for
that represent Tanner oh
um
yeah yeah I then then why is the non
liability clause in there if it's not a
form of legal protection for these for
the state the EFA and the scholarship
organization uh I I'm not a lawyer
either and I never wanted to be one so
um I'm just asking from a you know
untrained point of view here this no
liability uh clause or uh is specific to
the awarding or the use of the
EFA so it doesn't mean that the
organization's free from other
purposes we represent Tanner do you have
any
followup no I I get like I said uh we're
both struggling I think with uh not
being lawyers on this particular issue
but it just seems
um it's it it just kind of Bo limited
liability and non-liability clauses kind
of uh take special Focus from me
so thank you very much uh represent
Woodcock you you have your hand up
I do the last line if I may Mr chairman
2425 uh looking at 25 specifically uh
assuming this this uh bill passes
through all the pieces of legislation
that needs to go through what what is
your expectation of the earliest
starting
date the earliest what what did you
say could you could you I didn't catch
the last part please I'm just ask a
number I'm s lost on line 25 what what
is the earliest you believe if this bill
passes through all the steps what when
do you believe this the earliest this
bill will be in
effect time why date
wise it say uh I
um I believe it's going to uh take some
time to set up um I would hope that uh
if the uh bill is passed and signed into
uh law and good timing um there uh might
be the opportunity to start um uh
awarding uh accounts um in the fall or
uh um winter semester as well
possibly
followup Noe that's very clear thank you
thank you thank
you okay there are there any more
comments regarding the bill uh We've
certainly gone now taken the time to
walk through it and I appreciate some of
the comments have been uh important for
people to listen to and and perhaps even
to look at you know um uh possibilities
of maybe needed change I don't know but
uh that's up open for discussion right
now uh amongst the the writers of the
bill um
Mr chair yes I want to we appreciate the
patience of the committee and looking at
all these uh this is a critical bill
that's facing the legislature and we've
taken an appropriate amount of time to
deal with this uh we've been at this for
almost two and a half hours now uh would
it be appropriate the we would like to
caucus but I think it might be a good
time to have a break before we actually
start the debate on the bill we would
like to take about a 20 minute caucus if
you if we
may yes and I I'm even looking possibly
right now based upon what has been
discussed here um and I know that there
are some typo errors or errors in here
that result from legislative Services
I'm more inclined right now to take
action on this thing first thing uh
tomorrow
morning fine and if that's your decis to
wait and act on it tomorrow morning then
we will Reserve our caucus for a later
time yes and I think that you know given
all that's been said I think it'd be
wise uh um you know to to wait until
tomorrow morning uh I know we're under
the deadline of is this an early Bill to
get everything out but I it's it's it's
an important bill as it's been discussed
here in the last two plus
hours uh so uh I I will uh recess the
discussion on this bill and we'll bring
it up on the top of the docket tomorrow
morning thank you Mr chair gives ample
time for caucusing too amongst various
folks um I'm also going to take about a
f minute break right now there's some of
us been sitting in chairs here and it's
time to get up and stretch those legs um
also to maybe take a walk across the
hallway so uh so we'll come back
back yeah at around quarter after this
clock say it's about 7 or eight after
right now good quarter after the hour
we'll come
back everybody make don't everybody run
that
buch
okay it's dry in
here let's go
home they need to have a humidifier in
here or something it's just awful
okay can uh folks hear me out
there thank you very much uh I was just
commenting to folks here we need to get
a humidifier in this room everybody's
eyes are are bloodshot because you know
it's dry air and it's winter time yeah
was all us okay uh there a lot of people
there or is it just I meanit
meeting well there's there there there's
there's nine people in the room at this
point in time yes 10 or 10 what 10
because
Janine but in the morning it's great but
in the afternoon time you know it just
gets I guess it's not moving around
either okay thank you very much uh so we
have recessed uh hb20 till tomorrow
morning okay at at nine o'clock we'll
we'll pick that up at 9 o tomorrow
morning um the other bill which we have
in front of us now is
608 and uh I think you all have a
Amendment for that plus you may have
received also the uh an analysis of of
uh the
dollars that was sent out by
ume
um where where there there is a question
in that one uh that I'm I'm I'm very
concerned with the the uh how the money
is allocated to some districts are
losing huge amounts and that's all
dating back to the stabilization issue
which started in 2012 and has haunted us
all these years in fact actually even
started prior to 2012 yeah and to um
make some of the districts whole um as
they did that back in 2008 there was a
small hold harmless I am very much
thinking of putting a small hold
harmless it would cost around $25
million to hold harmless and to then uh
Mak the bill a little bit more palatable
my primary need our goal is to get a
bill that can go
onto uh house
finance and be a working
tool to um start moving us towards um
some kind of a b any budget that's going
to be reflective of of some of those
goals we all have of trying to help the
the districts that need the help and the
children who need the help great wa so
what are where I'm looking at right now
is that I have received uh information
from uh the folks over the Department of
Education on that the analysis came in
today for the first time I saw it and
I'm not pleased what I'm looking at um
I've also talk talked with them on the
phone since and they are crafting uh
some uh support to the language to build
that might help us better um send a
better Bill and regardless whether you
support it or you don't support it I'd
like to make sure we have the best
possible product for the 608 moving
forward um if if uh we can do that then
what I'd like I'm going to do is I'm
going to recess the hearing on 608 also
to tomorrow morning uh the other bills
which we have
scheduled uh are not early bills those
are not early bills so that allows us
the morning to look at both of these
bills and to try to make some decision
one way or the
other so um I don't think there's any
need to get into much of a discussion on
608 at this point in time seeing that we
will be uh into that tomorrow
morning comments Mr
represent B what time do we have to have
these bills done by tomorrow morning
we're going to have to have them done by
noon repan luno thank you Mr chair um uh
sing 608 was scheduled
for I
mean it was scheduled for being EXA
right so um are are we going to be
uh holding a
hearing no we already had the hearing no
we've already we've already had the
hearing that's what I thought and and uh
as we have done many times before with
all sorts of bills especially some of
the previous funding bills we have
modified them you and I have modified
them together when we gone over the LBA
and looked at the calculator you know
and and and uh made those uh subsequent
changes uh this is what it's occurring
right now and i' I'd like to have that
opportunity to do it right yeah I I
don't um uh Mr chair I don't have a
problem with that I just I thought I
heard you use the word hearing before I
I'm so tired right now Dave you know
it's just like I my having a hard time
looking at the screen no that that
that's fine and and you know I I I I do
appreciate the fact that that that you
sent over an amendment yesterday and
then there was another amendment to 608
this morning and that that other
amendment that literally just minor
changes do do you are you looking at
Material changes to to the bill in a new
Amendment or are you looking at updated
Financial I'm looking Dave at
representative luno just keep it proper
I guess okay even though we know each
other um I i' I've looked at uh the that
uh analysis which is just a a quick
analysis done by uh Matt over at the uh
at at the the uh Department of Education
by Mark right right by Mark excuse me
Mark and and
um I don't like some of the figures I'm
seeing and then I I I looked at it and I
and I I think we both probably would
look at and say well a lot of this is
resultant of where we've been on
stabilization and uh I want to look back
at 2020 not the year where we had the
onetime money last year looking back at
2020 and finding out what it has to in
using that as a
base um and and looking to see if
there's a need for a hold harmless as
they did with the joint um study back in
2008 there was a a small hold harmless
if you go back and look at that there as
well um we're we're living with this
this stabilization which is uh a part of
our past and funding here in the state
and uh it's it's going to be difficult
to get out of that trench um so um I I
think that there's a way to least get
this forward I personally am a lot like
um Representative Steve Smith I want to
see something come through that we can
basically afford as a state that's
sustainable and it's going to meet the
needs of the students that we've all
discussed and right now um as 6 608
stands we it needs more work and I'm
hoping that we can get something done if
not
um then I I I see everything being done
through hb1 and
hb2 right and and so I i' I'd like us to
be able to really uh send something over
at least uh gives a a vehicle for for
use so and that's it I I can't offer
anything more on that this evening um I
I look forward to discussion tomorrow
although we're going to have to try
we've had a very good discussion
regarding hb20 this this afternoon a lot
of good comments uh we've got to look at
that um and uh I I've got to get some
quick leg uh language out to legislative
services this afternoon and they head
out in about you know 35 minutes or so
so 4:00 is when they close shop down so
I I I've got to scoot and and really
start doing some work with
Caitlyn so with that is there anything
else at this evening I would suspect
that if we put with recessing this bill
and recessing 20 um that we will not be
able to get to all those bills um that
are other bills on the Thursday docket
uh we we'll get things done in the
morning there's a possibility we could
get to a few of those bills like um
maybe the Civics testing uh that's the
old immigration test we've all talked
about at one time or other um we can be
looking at you know I'm not going to
look at anything that's really going to
be um long and drawn out these are not
early bills although I do want to let
everybody know that by the 18th of March
we need to have our bills out some of
the bills we're not going to be able to
get out we should probably just retain
and work on them um and hold them for
the second year of the of this banum but
there are some good bills ahead of us
and and some of them are curricular
bills and directly relating to school
students in schools we need to address
all those even that the bill that's
dealing with food service program I I I
I think there's a lot of Merit to that I
I was supportive of that last year of
allowing surplus food to be used by
those youngsters that really could
benefit from that food out in Indiana so
there are some there's some good stuff
out in front of us uh we just got to
look at it and try to tweak it and make
it you know work and a answer those
questions I would appreciate anybody
that's involved with that bill to be
looking at what we decided in the
previous year and saying were there some
issues that were brought up that we can
try to get an amendment put together to
perhaps help it uh and that applies all
those bills I saw your hand up
representative Le it's okay thank you
you're good
yep okay so I got to run because I have
I got to I got to get legislative
Services working legisl have has been
working but it's it's the stuff we're
getting back there's there errors and I
think it's not because of folks it's
because of the rush everybody's under
and they're trying to get things done
quickly haste makes waste right so
everybody have a good afternoon and
thank you for your your listening and
and comments
today take
care thanks r